[Musique]
enfin bonjour jours nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne internet qui s'appelle
singer view nous sommes en direct est-ce
que vous pouvez vous présenter
succinctement
succinctement michel onfray donc 61 ans
j'ai dit souvent que c'est important
pour moi que mon père était ouvrier
agricole ma mère femme de ménage que je
sors de ce milieu que je lui restent
fidèles j'écris une centaine de livres
une dizaine de recueils de poèmes dont
tout le monde se moque une vingtaine de
livres sur des sur des artistes dont des
artistes contemporains tout le monde
s'en moque également une
douzaine ou un peu plus de deux livres
sur une contre histoire de la
philosophie mais on veut absolument que
je suis un philosophe polémiste et donc
on est intéressé que par les textes dans
lesquels j'utilise du cynisme d'une
unique cynisme dans l'esprit de diogène
de l'ironie dans l'esprit de swift tout
voltaire et des textes dans lesquels
j'essaie aussi de penser l'actualité
donc il ya une espèce de figure qui
n'est pas moi qui est une figure
médiatique moi je sais qui je suis et
cette figure médiatique génère aussi
bien la vénération que la détestation je
ne suis pas dupe de cette espèce de
duplication ce qui fait que quand on
quand on m'insulte je sais que c'est une
espèce d'avatar qu'on insulte et quand
on fait mon éloge je sais que c'est
aussi l'éloge de l'avatar que comme
qu'on me prête et que ma réalité des
taux au delà de ça dire ce que je veux
et qui je veux quand je veux comme je le
veux ta luxe absolu c'est à dire de ne
dépendre de rien et de personne c'est de
se dire si j'ai ça à dire je ne vais pas
me retenir parce que j'aurai un patron
qui me dira il faut pas le dire j'aurais
des crédits qui disparaîtront pas ce que
j'aurais parlé parce que je n'aurai pas
une place dans la hiérarchie parce qu'on
me virerais de mon poste où je ne sais
quoi donc je dis ce que j'ai à dire et
ça passe pour révolutionnaire ça passe
pour polémique alors qu'on estime jamais
que quand un autre philosophe tient des
propos qui sont évidemment dans le sens
du vent maastricht il est à un polémiste
la polémique s'est finalement
l'insultent qu'on réserve à celui qui ne
pense pas comme il faudrait poser parce
je vous coupe une seconde je vais
demander à la communauté qui est sûre
discorde chez qu'elles sont avec nous
est-ce que vous avez du sang sur
internet
3 2 1 est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un merci
pour le son le son est revenue désolé
pour cette petite aparté des fois on a
des problèmes de synchronisation mais je
pense que le son est passé bon mais de
toutes les façons il nous reste deux
heures donc on va pouvoir
s'expliquer
on revient sur le côté polémiste est ce
que vous pensez qu'à l'heure actuelle il
ya une forme de maccarthysme
sur les penseurs sur les les nouveaux
influenceurs est ce que vous pensez
qu'on a pu le droit d'entendre est ce
qu'on n'a plus le droit de faire parler
qu'est-ce qui se passe ah oui c'est vrai
mais moi je le vois très précisément
c'est à dire qu'
il ya des endroits où on n'est pas
invités à des endroits quand on est
invité on est invité pour se justifier
il faut qu'on explique si on est
vraiment maréchaliste pétainiste si on
soutient dolphy clair si on n'a pas voté
marine le pen la dernière fois donc des
endroits où on ne va pas des endroits où
quand on y va il faut absolument de
justifier et puis des endroits où quand
on y va on est là juste parce que l'on
sait qu'on fait on fait le buzz et que
finalement c'est bon pour l'audience un
certain nombre de gens totalement signé
qu'ils disent mais c'est très bien quand
on habite en free fait de l'audience
donc il faut fabriquer de l'audience et
on fabrique pas de l'audience avec des
propos intelligents fabrique de
l'audience avec ce qui rend possible le
buzz donc la petite phrase le petit truc
qui permettrait de dire eh bien fameuse
punchlines il a dit ceci est dit cela et
on réduit tout à deux ou trois phrases
on intervient c'est pas 25 minutes par
exemple il reste deux phrases et de
phrases sont sortis du contexte reprise
est dupliquée par les réseaux sociaux
qui veulent absolument que je sois ceci
ou cela donc ils font dire à ma phrase
qu' évidemment je n'aurais jamais dit
quand j'étais jeune et que je lisais
malraux je n'y comprenais pas grand
chose parce que quand on lit les textes
de malraux sur sur l'art et qu'il met en
relation un masque dogon qui met en
relation avec eux une la statuaire
romaine mais éventuellement
une écriture du linéaire b mycéniens
genre de choses on dit tout ça
formidable mais je ne connais pas toutes
ces références donc je vais avoir du mal
à comprendre ce qu'est véritablement le
propos de de malraux et ce sont des
propos de civilisation et j'ai l'âge qui
me permet de penser en termes de
civilisation puis la culture si on
travaille moi depuis 17 ans je lis je
prends des notes et je me dis moi l'on
peut faire aujourd'hui un travail de
civilisation donc vous poser une
question sur la france il faut la
remettre en relation avec l'europe et il
faut mettre l'europe en relation avec le
judéo-christianisme ce qui rend possible
un concept qu'il celui de l'occident
donc on ne peut pas penser le statut de
la france sans penser à l'occident ce
qu'est l'occident je pense que quand
hunting tonnes a parlé du choc des
civilisations il avait évidemment raison
il suffit de lire aujourd'hui hunting
tonnes il est mort depuis et mai il
avait annoncé un certain nombre de
choses qui se sont produites depuis et
il y avait une thing tonnes qui passait
pour un homme de droite et le dernier
homme de fukuyama qui nous disait que
c'était terminé il n'y avait plus
d'histoire et que le la démocratie avait
triomphé sur la totalité de la planète
depuis que le mur de berlin s'était
effondré qui avait pris de bloc
soviétique moi je persistais à penser
non pas en termes de droite de gauche ça
fait un petit moment que j'ai laissé ça
de côté mais en terme de justice de
justesse de vérité est ce que c'est vrai
ce que dit hunting tonnes est ce que
c'est vrai qu'il y à un dernier homme
que c'est la fin de l'histoire et c'est
le deal fukuyama ou est ce que il faut
penser ailleurs et autrement donc moi je
j'ai répondu dans des cadences en disant
démarrons avec cette fiction qui est
jésus qui est un personnage conceptuel
juif c'est à dire les juifs disent le
messie est à venir et puis parmi les
juifs y en a qui dit non il peut à venir
est déjà venu et il s'appelle jésus et
donc on fabrique autour de ce personnage
conceptuel une histoire qui toute la
mythologie de l'histoire sainte après on
va lui trouver un père une mère jésus
marie joseph gaspard melchior balthazar
balthazar un visage une barbe et sert à
rien de tout ça n'existe qu'une
description physique de jésus dans les
évangiles et donc on va fabriquer une
idéologie à partir de laquelle on va
produire ce qui s'appelle l'occident le
judéo christianisme c'est constantin qui
l'empereur qui au début du 4e siècle dit
bon on arrête avec toutes ces sectes là
et
une seule de ces sectes chrétiennes va
devenir une religion c'est une religion
c'est une secte ya réussi et le
christianisme commence à s'installer
durablement dans un espace qui est
devenu l'espace occidental
toutes les civilisations sont vivantes
et je suis pas marxiste en ce sens les
marxistes ont une conception extrêmement
mécaniste c'est comme un lego qu'ont
démontré et puis voilà mais dans un
égout ya pas de vie il faut une
perspective vitaliste et la perspective
italie ce télé chez hegel et spengler
est légitime by enfin tous ces gens qui
pensent en termes de civilisation et qui
nous disent mais la civilisation elle
n'est elle croit elle à un moment d'acmé
de pleine puissance puis à un moment
donné ou étendre descente et puis elle
sans vagues disparaît et laisse la place
à une autre c'est schengen ça c'est dans
les leçons sur la philosophie de
l'histoire et donc on voit bien il ya
assure sumer babylone il ya les
égyptiens même éventuellement avant
stone age lascaux et puis même plus plus
plus qu'une manière plus proche les
grecs les romains donc un monde
gréco-romain les juifs les chrétiens
donc un monde judéo-chrétien et cette
civilisation européenne qui elle dure
depuis bondir à la naissance d'un jésus
effectif enfin au mas la naissance de ce
jésus donc ça fait vingt siècles
cette civilisation et les comme
quelqu'un qui aurait un ancien que quoi
c'est à dire que il est bien évident que
quand quelqu'un à vingt siècles et il
n'est pas le même que quand il est jeune
quand il est jeune il est vivant il est
puissant il ya une force il un rapport à
la ville une vitalité d'une puissance
quand on s'oppose à lui il a de quoi
répond une espèce d'immunité qui fait
qu' il ya une pluie yens pleine
puissance des civilisations là on est
autour du 12e siècle donc on est on est
pas dans un dans une lecture du genre ah
c'est la décadence depuis mai 68 ou
basse et la décadence
depuis 1789
non je dis c'est le décadent le début de
la décadence depuis que la rationalité
est arrivé au jour et que la foi n'a
plus suffi quand il a fallu dire que le
dieu étaient ceux ci qu'ils étaient ceux
là et c'est quand on a eu des gens comme
saint thomas d'aquin par exemple la
somme théologique pour moi c'est pas
l'acmé de la civilisation c'est le début
de la fin ça rend possible ensuite la
renaissance nous en sommes à cet état où
effectivement nous allons disparaître
l'occident va disparaître il ya aucune
raison pour qu'il puisse continuer à
durée puisque ce qui faisait sa
fondation c'est à dire le christianisme
ne fonctionne plus même chez les
chrétiens les chrétiens ne croit plus à
la parousie les chrétiens ne croit plus
en faire au purgatoire ou au paradis les
chrétiens ne croit plus à satan au
diable les chrétiens ne croit plus
forcément à l'eucharistie ne nous
croient plus à la virginité de marie à
la transsubstantiation à ce genre de
choses tout ce qui était d'augmenter
dogmatique dogmatisme si je posais une
adhésion une fois tout ça a disparu on a
une espèce de pape aujourd'hui qui est
un boy scout qui nous dit que le bien le
mal c'est là il faut aimer ceux ci il
faut aimer cela fera attention à la
planète enfin jean paul 2 ses gratte
attenberg dans la transcendance et on se
dit est ce que ça peut suffire est-ce
que c'est avec ça qu'on fait la grandeur
d'une civilisation
j'habite à caen en normandie et de ma
fenêtre j'ai l'abbaye aux dames afin de
la bo d'un même à droite et l'abbaye aux
hommes dans laxe de mon bureau
guillaume le conquérant et est capable
de fabriquer deux abbayes en une
vingtaine d'années il n'a pas fait que
ça il a fait un château où il a fait
d'autres choses en normandie puis les
batailles hastings etc vous avez la
cathédrale de la sagrada familia par
exemple qui est un exemple extrêmement
intéressante pour moi parce que
barcelone vous dites voilà c'est une
c'est une cathédrale qui était décidé à
la fin du 19ème prétendument construite
au xxème siècle inachevé au 21ème siècle
qui a été consacrée pas un pape qui
devenu un pape démissionnaire qui est
toujours vivant mais qui est
démissionnaire et il y est mais benoît
16 à l'époque mais et qu' il ya quelque
temps a fait l'objet d'un
projet d'attentats islamistes je pense
que tout est dit c'est à dire quand
guillaume le conquérant incapable de
fabriquer des abbayes des châteaux en
feintant nous en sur trois siècles on
n'est pas capable de finir la sagrada
familia donc je pense que ce qui fait
l'essentiel de notre civilisation c'est
à dire à fond judéo chrétien je n'oublie
pas qu'il y ait eu aussi la révolution
française la laïcité etc bien sûr mais
tout ça procède d'une vidéo
christianisme eh bien je dis que le
judéo christianisme est épuisé ce qui
veut dire que nous sommes dans une
civilisation d'épuisement ou nous
n'aimons que ce qui nous détestent - ça
va mieux c'est tout ce qui nous détruit
c'est formidable et il ya
une passion pour la déconstruction pas
seulement la déconstruction sens
philosophique du terme je songe aux eaux
structuraliste à foucault à deleuze à
tous ces gens là mais tout ce qui
détruit est formidable il faut détruire
la vérité même en parle aujourd'hui de
postes vérité il faut détruire
l'histoire l'histoire n'existe plus une
question de les savoir qui a fait quoi
comment les choses ont pu fonctionner ce
qui a été de ce qu'on était les traites
négrières donc il ya une méchante trets
et la traite négrière
assurée par les blancs mais finalement
il ya une bonne trets et la traite qui
est fabriqué par les musulmans et
christiane taubira quand elle parle de
crimes contre l'humanité souhaite
absolument qu'on ne parle pas de cette
de cette traite clamer qu'on parle
plutôt de telle autre je veux bien c'est
de l'idéologie non mais on n'appelle pas
ça de l'histoire donc il ya plus
d'histoires ya plus de vérité il ya plus
de réflexion il ya plus de méditation il
ya plus de silence il ya plus de calme
il ya plus de lecture il ya plus
d'écriture à proprement parler c'est à
dire qu'on est dans une espèce de
triomphe de l'instant on est dans le lay
que je nique et donc on est un peu comme
avec les romains quoi c'est colbert
voilà
je sais pas rosa luxembourg voilà mais
pour d'autres c'est ça et donc on se dit
mais ce qu'on pourrait pas être un peu
plus subtil un petit peu plus complexe
que que d'être dans cette logique
binaire tu es mon ami tu es mon ennemi
et si tu es mon ami c'est parce que tu
partages les même hystérie que moi et si
tu es mon ennemi c'est parce que tu
luttes éventuellement contre contre les
hystéries je pense que la france en est
à un stade de presque 2 commun avancé je
dirais enfin de de coma est de deux
morts annoncés je suis une espèce
d'esthète en matière de politique c'est
à dire que je ne crois pas qu'on
pourrait changer véritablement les
choses mais bon avec stephen simmonds on
a créé cette revue front populaire on
fait comme si on devait pouvoir changer
les choses il faut résister il faut être
debout
l'époque est à la vache issement est à
la génuflexion est à l'aplatissement
même à tous les sens physiquement on a
vu des avis des policiers s'allonger en
dix ans la vox populi va faire la loi et
je mets un genou en terre ou
et à plat ventre plus encore on a eu
récemment ministre de de la dune de
l'intérieur qui nous disait qu'il était
prêt lui aussi évoqué un problème à
mettre un genou à terre que par ailleurs
la loi était secondaire parce que
l'émotion était première c'est
formidable c'est à dire que quand un
ministre de l'intérieur nous dit que
l'émotion fait la loi et que la loi
finalement on verra ça plus tard le
droit c'est pareil c'est pas bien grave
tout ça alors ça veut dire que n'importe
qui peut revendiquer son émotion une
civilisation dans laquelle l'émotion
fait la loi ça s'appelle la barbarie
c'est plus une civilisation ça s'appelle
la barbarie une future civilisation
s'annonce je pense que l'islam jouera un
jour à son rôle exactement de la même
manière que la chine jouera son rôle
c'est un bloc confucéen un bloc
musulmans de y avoir un bloc hindouiste
également mais sont des blocs qui comme
avec la tectonique des plaques joue et
ils font de telle sorte que la plaque
judéo chrétienne va se trouver aplati
elle va elle va disparaître alors ça ça
prendra un certain temps je sais pas je
sais pas combien on voit bien que dans
le tuilage ce vers quoi nous allons et
c'est le début de la fin et le début du
début c'est à dire que le temps de
décadence dans lequel nous sommes est un
temps de barbarie mais cette barbarie va
générer une autre civilisation c'est la
civilisation du transhumanisme et on
voit bien aujourd'hui que tous ces gens
qui prétendent vouloir défaire le
l'ordre mondial sont des
anticapitalistes qui donne c'est quoi
des altermondialistes qui sont
prétendument des anti fascistes ou l
fascisme font des gens qui travaillent
pour le capital ce sont des les idiots
utiles du capital puisqu'il s'agit de
détruire les identités toutes les
identités la nature par exemple identité
naturelle on met des produits pour
détruire les abeilles et quand on a
détruit les abeilles en invente des
petits robots pollinisateurs ben robot
c'est formidable ce que ça s'achète ça
se vend ses traçable ça permet de savoir
qui fait quoi quand comment et c'est
tous ces gens qui veulent absolument que
nous louions les utérus des femmes
pauvres et que nous vendions les
embryons en estimant qu'ils sont de
gauche voire libération le l'observation
des gens qui sont de droite je me dirai
pas d'extrême droite puisque c'est
devenu aujourd'hui d' insulte mais je
pense que tous ces gens là travaillent
dans une même direction qui est la
direction du transhumanisme le
transhumanisme c'est quoi ce sont les
gars femmes
c'est pas compliqué c'est à dire quand
ces gens descendent dans la rue en dix
ans le fascisme ne passera pas ils sont
juste en train de faire le nécessaire
pour que google pour que facebook pour
que tous ces gens là puissent par boucle
lots de masques puisse parvenir à
réaliser ce projet transhumanistes c'est
à dire que notre civilisation judéo
chrétienne est en passe de disparaître
une autre civilisation s'annonce c'est
celle dans laquelle des individus comme
elon musk sont capables de financer des
projets que la nasa ne peut plus
financer c'est à dire lots de masques
dit moi je sors mon chèque on chez qui
est je fais un chèque et conquête
spatiale je vais envoyer des hommes sur
mars la nasa les etats-unis disent ne
pas suivre on ne peut pas ça veut dire
que cette disparition des états rend
possible le surgissement d'un certain
nombre d'individus qui eux sont les
richesses planétaire ces gens là disent
moi je peux tout acheter je peux tout
acheter j'achète ce que je veux quand je
veux je peux acheter une ville je peux
acheter tout ce que je viens truc que je
peux pas être htc la santé et c'est la
vie je suis richissime je peux tout
acheter mais finalement je vieillis j'ai
mon âge etc que dit ces gens là je veux
vivre toujours c'est le symptôme du
narcissisme absolue de l'égotisme
absolue ce qui se fait d elle fuit en
permanence celui qui photographient ce
qu'ils mangent que la cuisine qu'il est
en train de faire ce qui leur a déféqué
enfin cette espèce d'égocentrisme
perpétuelle fait que on a des individus
qui dit mais moi je veux pas mourir
débrouillez-vous je vais vous payez vous
donner beaucoup d'argent mais fait de
telle sorte que mon cerveau tiennent le
coup sentant mon coeur tiennent le coup
son temps et c'est assez le
transhumanisme et ça suppose la
marchandisation de la totalité de ce qui
existe il faut marchandises et la
planète il faut marchandises est la
nature il faut marchandises et les
produits de nature va falloir
marchandises et l'air l'eau les arbres
la forêt etc les animaux les insectes
ont marchandises tout ça et on s'en va
vers une espèce de mécanisation
généralisée de la planète première des
civilisations secondes peut-être parce
que effectivement la civilisation
chrétienne s'est voulue universel
mes premières civilisations franchement
globalisante totalisante voire
totalitaire il suffit d'aller voir du
côté de orwell 1984 ou du côté de exclu
le meilleur des mondes pour voir ce qui
nous attend aussi trendy qui s'appelle
théorie de la dictature qui est une
lecture de 1984 de la ferme des animaux
qui montre que c'est pas à venir 1984
c'est déjà venu c'est ici et maintenant
vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
question de la liberté de la censure de
la possibilité de s'exprimer on est en
plein dedans le fameux novlangue on y
est totalement qu'est ce qu'un anti
fasciste et c'est quoi le fascisme je
suis en train de relire un truc que j'ai
eu il ya très longtemps sur les mémoires
d'un fasciste de dirt battait ses terres
parus dans les années soixante quinze ou
seize c'est jean jacques pauvert je me
dis mais qu'est ce que c'est est
historiquement le fascisme on voit bien
à écrire qu'un et les décombres 600
pages puis ensuite les mémoires d'un
fasciste 300 pages donc ça fait vraiment
mille pages pour savoir ce qui est un
fasciste on se dit sauf à dévitaliser ce
terme là il n'y a pas de fascisme
aujourd'hui en france ou en europe je ne
vois pas à quoi ressemble à quoi
ressemblerait à sa gym qui ne serait ni
armée ni casque ni beauté etc c'est à
sauf éventuellement à se dire mais après
tout lui que le fascisme qui est raciste
et du côté des racialiste qui est
misogyne et du côté d'une espèce de deux
néo féminisme qui suppose que l'égalité
des femmes suppose l'infériorité des
hommes que ce fascisme il est dans dans
le refus de la raison silas hrbaty on
cogne on ne dialogue pas refus du débat
j'insulte jeu
l'antisémitisme est perpétuel avec des
mots les mots grossiers enfin des mots
vulgaires qu'on n'utilise donc on se dit
mais le fascisme n'est pas là où les
anti fasciste disent qu'il est il est
très précisément l'un où ils font ce
qu'ils font et donc nous en sommes dans
cette nous sommes dans sept noms sept
dans ce moment de l'histoire où des anti
fasciste active néo à mener au fascisme
une nouvelle forme de faillite sous
forme d'islam au gauchisme jamais il
n'aurait toléré que qu'on puisse dire
que les femmes sont inférieures que les
homosexuels sont à mettre au bûcher qu'
il y à une inégalité entre les races ou
les religions etc si c'était les
catholiques qui avaient dit des choses
pareilles mais si on dit exactement la
même chose et que ce sont des musulmans
qui venise alors là pour le coup ça
devient absolument impensable et
défendent al on se dit mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cet état de décadence
mental ou la raison n'existe plus où la
déraison fait la loi houle argumentation
n'existe plus mais où l'insultent appris
le pain ou le dialogue et le débat
n'existe plus mais où on tabasse on
insulte on méprise et sur les réseaux
sociaux pourvu qu'on soit caché derrière
son anonymat ont la possibilité de tout
dire je vois une parenthèse juste pour
dire que stéphane simon et moi créeront
cette revue front populaire elle n'est
connue que de lui et de moi chacun qui a
écrit dans la revue savait qu'il avait
écrit ce texte là mais personne ne
connaissait la revue elle est arrivée
dans les kiosques le 23 juin je crois
trois semaines en amont la totalité de
la presse avait décidé que nous étions
des nazis des fascistes des antisémites
que nous étions des rats que nous étions
doriot et c'est
parce que nous faisons peur
toute la presse appartient à des gens
qui sont des milliardaires et ses
milliardaires sont subventionnés parce
qu'ils ne vendent pas assez de journaux
c'est assez extravagant c'est à dire que
tous les patrons de presse le monde
libération etc à tous les jours nous
tous les tous les magazines font entre
les mains de fortune qui pourrait
effectivement assumer le travail à perte
des journalistes la vente du des numéros
ne suffit pas eh bien les legends paix
se dire l'impôt les légendes donne de
l'argent au monde pour que le monde
puisse continuer à les insulter et
insulté les gilets jaunes que libération
puisse me faire savoir que gilet jaune
sont tous des nazis des fascistes après
avoir pris de l'argent dans la poche des
gilets jaunes pour dire on va pouvoir
payer ce journal qui appartient à des
milliardaires qui eux ont intérêt à
avoir ces journaux pour quelle raison
parce qu'ils défendent l'idéologie
dominante parce qu'il s'agit globalement
de travailler à la logique
transhumanistes il s'agit de dire fin
des nations disparition de la france si
vous commencez à dire le mot france que
vous utilisez même vous même en disant
mais où en est la france au delà déjà
posé la question de la france mais elle
est déjà morte et l'errance elle pue et
les moisir je renvoie bhl je revois
solaire soi ou à tous ces gens là donc
fin des nations disparition des nations
fabriquons l'europe de jean monnet jean
monnet et quand même payé par la cia les
mémoires de jean monnet ont été écrites
par des gens qui recevait d'échec de la
cia to c est documenté on le sait et le
projet de cette europe est un projet
libre le poste national qui va vers un
autre projet qui est celui du
gouvernement planétaire celui des gars
femmes c'est à dire que quand vous
arrivez que vous déboulez avec un
journal en dix ans mais nous n'existons
qu'avec nos abonnés nous avons pléthore
d'abonnés 40000 personnes qui arrivent
et puis le dise voilà ça nous intéresse
on vous donne de l'argent on est libre
on appartient au lecteur on n'appartient
pas des patrons donc nous on a le souci
de la vérité de la justice et de la
justesse on n'a pas le souci de dire il
faut détruire tout ce qui est souverain
au sens noble du terme qu'est ce qu'un
souverain c'est quelqu'un qui est le
maître chez lui qui est le maître de
lui-même qu'il va mettre à parler du
souverainisme un peu plus tard j'en
profite pour passer une question
internet michel onfray nanterre t-il pas
le monde chrétien peu vite la france ne
représente pas le monde chrétien moderne
j'en profite vous parlez vous parliez de
subduction de
la civilisation judéo chrétienne ou
profit d'autres blocs comment vous voyez
la friction mise à part la friction
qu'on peut voir à l'heure actuelle
comment vous extrapolez la friction
qu'on va être amené à gérer quand cette
plaque va passer sous les autres ça à
faire trembler non non parce que ça se
fait doucement ça se passe tout de suite
là par exemple actuellement si on parle
vraiment tectonique des plaques ça se
passe doucement il ya un moment donné de
temps en temps quand il ya des chocs
évidemment il ya des tremblements de
terre et les tsunamis et c'est là qu'on
voit que ça bouge mais les plaques
bougent tout le temps alors nous parlons
d'un point de vue de la civilisation les
plaques bougent il ya des moments où
effectivement il ya il ya des des
manifestations qui sont extrêmement
visible qu'est ce que ça peut prendre
c'est une métaphore on va pas disserter
sur une métaphore mais que serait
l'équivalent d'un d'un tsunami ou d'un
tremblement de terre en termes de
civilisation est bien de dire si phil et
la guerre souci de la guerre civile nous
y sommes c'est à dire qu'il y a
actuellement en france les territoires
perdus de la république tout le monde en
convient et jusqu'au chef de l'état
jusqu'au ministre de l'intérieur
jusqu'au premier ministre jean castex
qui quand il a fait son discours à
l'assemblée nationale l'autre jour a
clairement dit que les choses se passer
comme ça
donc il ya des endroits dans lesquels la
loi n'est plus faite par là par la
république les espèces dans claf dans
lesquelles un mode de fonctionnement qui
est absolument tribales c'est en classe
sont armés et là on découvre qu'une
balle est arrivée dans le mollet d'un
pompier on dira il ya un truc il ya
quand même un truc rim et ça fait des
années qu'il ya un truc les banlieues
sont armés quand on est armé on utilise
des armes quand on utilise des armes on
envoie des balles et quand on envoie des
balles elle peut arriver dans les corps
des gens ils peuvent les tuer donc ça
arrive dans un mollet tant mieux pour le
bon pied et étant mieux éventuellement
pour probablement pour le coup pour
rappeler la plaie sociale appelons ça
comme ça pour ce qu'il en reste mais
imaginons que ça arrive dans la tête de
quelqu'un et que ce soit pas forcément
un pompier enfin comme tu auras un mort
voire des morts comme tu auras loti
l'équivalent d'un anti bataclan quand il
y aurait parlons conditionnalité
d'amande anti bataclan et bien par
exemple que des gens descendent dans un
endroit dix ans dans une mosquée on
arrive avec une kalachnikov et puis on
tire à vue et puis on fait un massacre
je rappelle que les victimes du bataclan
ont été photographiés que ces photos
sont interdites et personne ne les a vus
qu'est ce que c'est que cette obscénité
qu'il ne faudrait pas montré ils
rencontrent toutes les obscénités
possible sur le net tout les obscénités
possible s'y trouvent il ya une époque
vous n'aviez pas le droit de montrer les
têtes décapitées par des ch ah bon
pourquoi tout est possible mais mais
mais pas çà et là il ya des gens qui ont
été massacré des dizaines et des
dizaines de gens qui ont été massacrées
photographier ces photographies sont
interdites qui interdit et pourquoi quel
est le motif de l'interdiction de ces
photographies c'est le réel qui est
interdit c'est le réel qui est interdit
et voilà pourquoi on nous détestent nous
on veut faire une revue avec le réel et
les journaux font des revues avec des
fictions ils font des revues avec des
mythologies fondé rêver avec des
légendes il enseigne des choses qui
relèvent de la propagande voilà pourquoi
on est détesté simplement ont dit 'nous
on appartient au lecteur
plus on aura de lecteurs plus on sera
libre plus on aura d'argent plus on
prend on pourra faire des choses alors
après c'est michel onfray n'est
intéressé que par l'argent je suis des
années des années d'une veillée connaît
un bénévole pardon vous gagnez combien
avec le front populaire
avec chants populaires comme en son
temps le front populaire dommage pour
l'instant rien j'ai simplement dépensé
450 euros stéphane simon a dépensé 450
euros on a démarré cette aventure pour
l'instant on a gagné
tout ça fait quatre mois qu'on y
travaille on la rend n'a rien gagné donc
à côté michel onfray il gagne un peu de
pognon pas moi j'avais l'urgence oui
parce que j'étais obligé de doigts alors
ça après les jambes en croire c'est mon
épouse qui s'occupent de toutes ces
choses là et puis après vous avez un
gros contrat et après vous n'avez rien
donc parfois vous pouvez gagner 40 mille
euros parce que vous avez un gros
contrat et puis parfois rien du tout
pendant sept mois
et puis après on peut voir deux fois un
contrat de 40 mille euros qui va arriver
puis et c'est donc il faudrait faire un
lissage sur l'année et j'ai la chance
d'avoir une épouse qui depuis des années
me dispense d'avoir raconté et gère
absolument tout ça mais je fais partie
des gens riches si je ne peux pas vous
donner un chiffre exact e mans mais
sachant ce que gagne mon frère cas par
exemple qui travaille dans une dans une
carrière et sachant ce qui éteint à ce
mythe je fais partie effectivement des
gens qui gagnent plusieurs smic donc
bien sûr que je suis riche j'ai écrit
plus de 130 livres dont certains se sont
vendus à plus de 1 plus de cent mille
exemplaires donc c'est facile de faire
le compte avec des contrats qui sont
autour de 10 12% pour des pour des
livres avec des prix publics c'est à
dire quand on a un cantona à retirer les
30% donc c'est facile n'importe qui peut
faire le total vous avez une base de
données où on sait combien de livres
j'ai vendu il suffit juste de faire le
calcul que je n'ai pas fait et puis on
saura combien j'ai gagné en fonction des
années on répartit ont fait de moyenne
et puis le chiffre républicain s'est
passé pas caché pas besoin d'aller aux
impôts il suffit de prendre une donne
une une
base je sais plus comment ça peut
laisser de base enfin bon et elle est
accessible chez les libraires et bien on
fait le calcul et puis on sait combien
je gagne mais je sais très bien que je
gagne ainsi pour ne pas avoir à
affronter c'est à dire que quand je
quand je vais dans un restaurant je
choisis le plat qui me plaît et puis
après je paye l'addition c'est ça un
riche c'est quelqu'un qui d'abord c'est
qui peut rentrer dans un restaurant
parce qu'il a vu le menu que le menu wii
play et quand il est en présence d'un
menu se dit je peux choisir ça parce que
j'ai envie de manger ça un prof c'est
celui qui se dit non dans cet endroit je
pourrais pas rentrer parce que je
n'aurai pas les moyens ou quiconque il y
rentre c'est qu'il va y rentrer mais une
fois parce que ça va être assez
exceptionnel et quand il va regarder le
menu est pas regarder ce qu'il va manger
vais regarder ce qu'il va payer donc je
sais que tu fais partie des gens riches
et ça ça fait partie du trajet de qui a
fait plus de cent livres dont certains
ddd succès librairie maintenant pour le
pour l'heure ce que je peux vous
répondre c'est qu'avec front populaire
je n'ai rien gagné et que j'ai un peu
perdu j'ai faim j'ai donné de l'argent
et puis je venais beaucoup de temps qui
pour le coup qui pour l'heure n'a pas
été payé on peut passer bonjour à
dorothée je joue et je pense que nous
écoutait pas on dit bonjour
on lui passe le bonjour on va revenir
sur la friction de la subduction de la
plaque judéo-chrétienne le pouvoir en
place le pouvoir macro vous pensez qu'il
va continuer de réagir d'une façon
épidermique à utiliser des technologies
qui créent des plaies de guerre celle et
gilet jaune il va se tendre encore plus
où il va essayer de renouer vers un
dialogue politique
je veux pas faire de prédictions
simplement c'est que la la la
constitution de 1958 ne va pas changer
ne va pas bouger c'est à dire qu'elle
donne les pleins pouvoirs à cet homme
est que la structure psychique de cet
homme ne va pas changer non plus donc
c'est peu probable et il pense qu'il
mourra comme ça qu'il est ainsi
constitué il a clairement dit qu'il
était l'homme du en même temps le en
même temps le mc ce sont ces initiales
sa 9e c'est devenu l'ailé ce sont les
initiales de en marche il a deux
alliances il se fait en permanence fort
de dire en même temps même temps que en
même temps qu'est puni comme dirait
l'autre en même temps qu'il en joue lui
m donc on peut pas être un chef d'état
quand on dit en même temps une porte
elle n'est pas en même temps ouverte et
en même temps fermer une femme n'est pas
en même temps enceinte et en même temps
par enceinte un homme qui ça peut le
faire mais bon pardon aux mathématiques
on trouve mathématiques quantique et les
mathématiques quantique dont l'épreuve
reste à apporter et je pense
qu'effectivement les mécaniques de la
mécanique quantique qui m'adressent
beaucoup notamment tout ce qui est
astronomique sur le terrain de la
physique quantique mais je pense que
tout ça reste encore à démontrer et
quand on nous dit qu'effectivement et
des particules très éloignées qui sont
en relation sans qu'on sache ce qui les
lie très précisément on se dit eh bien
cette thèse la rend possible toutes les
fictions je songe à l'homéopathie je
songe à la mémoire de l'eau benveniste
qui nous dit voilà vous mettez la clé
dans l'eau à de la scène par exemple à
paris et puis quand elle arrive à rouen
l'eau a gardé la mémoire de ces terrains
ce qui rend possible le vin bio
dynamique avec des pulvérisations de 2
grammes d'une poudre qui était faite
avec un mulot qu'on aura réduit en
cendres et on aura pulvérisé sa sur
trois hectares et d'un seul coup on aura
produit quelque chose de formidable on
aura un vin bio dynamique donc
finalement la physique quantique elle
permet tout le fameux chat de
schrödinger qui est vivant et qui est
mort en même temps donc tous les gens
qui pensent que les tables tourner que
les esprits sont susceptibles d'être
interrogé que les morts restent vivants
se réclament tous de la physique
quantique attention à la physique
quantique elle existe elle ne permet pas
tous réellement c'est aussi une
hypothèse de travail quand il y aura des
ordinateurs quantiques alors là
effectivement pourra dire que la
physique quantique a produit des effets
et quand on obtiendra les vitesses
quantique qui skie khimki surclassement
les vitesses qui sont les nôtres
actuellement avec tout le matériel que
vous utilisez la effectivement ce moment
là c'est des gens comme elon musk sont
très heureux parce que tous les
processus qui seront mécanique intégrés
dans le corps c'est à dire tous co2 ce
qui permettra de mettre des puces dans
les cerveaux pour parler de cette
manière là ça permettra d'obtenir les
vitesses qui seront des vitesses qui
sont celles de la pensée pensée qui est
la mienne actuellement et la pensée des
gens qui nous écoutent elle est
susceptible d'être mesurés il ya une
vitesse si on a la possibilité d'
artificialisés ces vitesses avec la
physique quantique alors à ce moment là
effectivement le transhumanisme aura
fait aura fait des pas et des grands pas
revenant sur les frictions les adhérents
en place est-ce que vous pouvez est ce
que vous pouvez imaginer
que le pouvoir deviennent beaucoup plus
violent qu'à l'heure actuelle
hélas oui je pense que je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui mettent du temps à
comprendre des choses mais c'est un peu
normal c'est pas forcément leur métier
si on est philosophe qu'on a passé une
partie de sa vie à lire à écrire à
travailler à penser à réfléchir à
essayer d'imaginer que des gens avaient
quand même penser beaucoup de choses
avant nous et que c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal de de savoir ce que ces
gens là avaient pensé l'histoire de la
philosophie n'est pas une fin en soi si
c'est une occasion de bien penser ce qui
a été déjà pensé ça nous permet
effectivement de comprendre un peu avant
les autres ce qui risque de se passer
moi quand je suis contre le traité de
maastricht en 1992 je
n'ai pas une culture extraordinaire je
suis un jeu parfait le compte du tennis
1h59 mais je veux dire que ce que je
sais me permet tout de même de me dire
mais non là il ya quelque chose qui va
pas avec cette ce renoncement la
souveraineté ça n'est pas possible ce
n'est pas pour ça donc c'est un débat en
92 entre des gens qui nous disent cette
europe qui n'existe pas encore qui est
une pure virtualité c'est le sens de
l'histoire où cette europe ceux qui n'en
veulent pas ce sont des
des suppôts de le pen des fascistes des
nazis des crétins des ruraux des
incultes desous diplômés des gens qui
vivent dans les villages et c'est donc
avec maastricht l'horizon indépassable
le sens de l'histoire la fin des guerres
de la misère de la pauvreté le plein
emploi etc et ça c'était à longueur de
journaux comprend bien pourquoi les
journaux sont achetés par des sons sont
détenus par des milliardaires et pour
quoi ils sont payés par l'argent public
et les impôts de tout le monde puisqu'il
s'agit d'endoctriner tout le monde avec
ça et puis on avait en face d'autres
qu'ils aiment et non pas du tout
l'europe ça va pas l'europe de
maastricht et la fin de la souveraineté
ça va être une catastrophe c'est la fin
des identités etc c'était deux visions
du monde et là en gros vous demander de
parier et puis parfois parié c'était
quoi c'était bas je préfère voter avec
chirac plutôt qu'avec jean marie le pen
s'était souvent ce genre de choses et
maintenant les gens 25 ou 30 années je
ne sais pas compter donc je plus de 92 à
aujourd'hui ils ont ces années-là qui
leur permettent de dire bon n'est plus
entre entre une hypothèse d une autre
hypothèse mais on est entre une
réalité et ce qui aurait pu être une
autre réalité alors on va pas dire s'il
n'y avait pas eu maastricht j aurais pas
eu ceci de cela on est dans l'uchronie
sait pas ce qui nous intéresse mais
juste de dire ah oui le plein emploi la
fin de la pauvreté de la misère du
chômage
l'amitié entre les peuples la fin du
racisme la disparition des guerres c'est
ce que vous nous aviez promis on a voté
pour vous je ne pars pas pour moi
j'avais déjà voté contre ce projet là
depuis toujours et aujourd'hui vous nous
proposez ça c'est à dire la guerre
civile les incivilités le racisme
l'antisémitisme alors aujourd'hui le
racisme ça s'appelle le racialisme
l'antisémitisme ça s'appelle aujourd'hui
ventis sionisme ont dit y a plus de
guerre commença n'ya plus de guerre mais
il ya des guerres civiles il ya des gens
qui travaillent et qui dorment dans
leurs et qui dorment dans leurs dans
leur voiture il ya des gens qui ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans la danse dans
certaines cités parce qu'ils savent très
bien que la loi ne fait plus la loi pour
le coup on se dit mais c'est ça que vous
nous aviez premier finalement pas du
tout ça marche pas on n'en veut plus de
ça donc je pense que des gens ont
compris que ce qu'on leur avait proposé
tête une marchandise avariée et que
globalement cette marchandise avariée
elle cache autre chose moi je le dis
depuis longtemps je dire mais elle cache
la disparition de des nations pour
fabriquer une europe fédérale qui elle
même est un rouage dans une grande
machine qui sera celle du gouvernement
planétaire qui sera leur haine
généralisée du capitalisme mondial voilà
maintenant dites moi que j'ai tort j'ai
quand même lu l'autre jour dans le
figaro un entretien entre bernard lévy
et philippe de villiers ou bernard-henri
lévy dit très précisément qu'il s'agit
désormais de penser à un impérialisme
européen il faut que l'europe fasse
empire face empire non pas phase plus
empire mais on se dit ah enfin la chose
est enfin dévoilée mais jacques attali
avait écrit un délit qui s'appelait qui
gouvernera le monde demain je crois
point d'interrogation donc la question
de la gouvernance mondiale et pose est
pourquoi n'en parle-t-on jamais pourquoi
le projet de jean monnet qui est très
précisément raconté dans ses mémoires
n'est-il pas clairement signifié
pourquoi est ce que françois mitterrand
mais jean monnet au panthéon en sachant
très bien que c'est très anti gaulliste
de célébrer jean-monnet puisque le
général de gaulle lui voulait une europe
des nations bien sûr l'europe tout le
monde veut l'europe une europe avec des
nations qui restent qui reste libre j'ai
quand on se marie on ne devient pas son
époux ne vient pas sa femme on fabrique
une communauté cette communauté se
constitue mon père pas les identités on
fusionne pas les identités on ne dit
plus tu n'es plus toile je ne suis plus
- et nous sommes un tiers un tiers
personnage est bien dans une dent dans
le rough c'est exactement la même chose
soit on se dit on dilue la france
l'italie l'espagne le portugal etc dans
une europe qui elle même est une grande
europe des marchés parce qu'elle n'est
que ça et sept grands d'europe de marché
elle est une courroie de transmission
pour les états unis qui eux sur le
navire amiral de tout ce qui est
transgénèse où sont les patrons des gars
femmes y en a t'il à paris un outil ou
en france où sont-ils en europe où se
trouve-t-il on sait bien que c'est pas
c'est pas là que ça se passe et ça se
passe probablement dans des endroits on
ne sait pas que ça s'y passe je ne pense
que s'il ya effectivement et il y en a
des gens qui travaillent sur le
transhumanisme en chine on ne sera pas
qui quand comment de quelle manière et
pourtant ils y travaillent à ce projet
et je pense que c'est la même chose en
inde et qu'il ya des on ad d une
intelligence indienne qui est
extrêmement importante extrêmement
intéressante une technologie très au
point avec en même temps bénarès la
misère la pauvreté mais son a1 a6 pardon
varanasi
bénarès
c'est le même enfin c'est le bénarès et
le nom d'anciens veine assez l'ancien
oui mais moi j'aime bien le l'ancien nom
bénarès kacm et red est bon je sais que
j'avais et j'ai fait un livre s'appelle
des bûchers de bénarès parce que
justement quand vous voyez le les gâte
et que vous saurez cdc de ce sont les
escaliers qui descendent sur le golf sur
le gange il vous avez là tous les gens
qui viennent mourir c'est un mouroir et
puis on apporte sur des brancards enfin
willy-brandt car les gens portent ça
avec les cadavres qui sont enroulés dans
des tissus avec des fleurs et puis on
vient les brûler et puis elle éprouve
qu'on ne brûle pas il ya les pauvres
cons brute des riches quand kim qui
brûle avec des ddd bois précieux puis
d'autres avec des mauvais bois puis doté
en balance les corps ici puis vous
faites un quart d'heure de marche et
vous avez vous avez l'équivalent des
champs-elysées quoi des voitures qui
passent qui vont qui viennent des
garçons ou des jeunes filles avec les
écouteurs d'iphone d'autres qui sont
assis sur un banc et qui sont en train
de pianoter sur un surnombre un
ordinateur il ya hélas les castes en
inde rendent possible au moins deux
indes alors il ya une haine qui est très
ancestrale ce qui se passa au fameux
gâteau de bénarès est effectivement
ce qu'il ya de plus ancestrales c'est
terrifiant comme comme on gomme
spectacle et puis après effectivement
cette ville hyper moderne
qui donnera le monde c'est intéressant
de parler de l'inde quand vous parlez de
dinde ancestrale est ce que vous pensez
que c'est cette même inde qui a créé le
mouvement indépendantiste
indépendantiste mais le mouvement très
radicale prouve âge pro tradition qui
tape sur tout ce qui bouge dès qu'on
mange de la viande nous dès qu'on touche
une vache est ce que vous pensez que
c'est un repli identitaire indiens aussi
en occident en inde et puis après en
occident non parce qu'on n'ose pas
pareil c'est à dire 1 1 de l'ornane si
vous réintégrer cette idée la
transmigration des âmes de ce qu'on
appelle la métempsycose de la mettant
son matos ne vous n'êtes jamais comme
que votre corps n'est jamais qu'un
passage pour votre âme qui elle durer
quand vous mourrez votre âme 5,1 en
fonction de la vie que vous aurez menée
et elle peut s'incarner dans mieux ou
dans moins bien suivront la vie que vous
aurez et il ya effectivement abandonnés
ou quand vous êtes un stade ou un sage
total eh bien on avait plus besoin d'une
incarnation et votre âme et s'en va dans
ce que la personne appelée une espèce de
/ ame c'est une espèce dame du cosmos
donc il ya toujours cette idée que les
animaux sont des vivants au même titre
que les humains et que on peut se
réincarner dans un animal et que parfois
on peut même en fait pour que l'on passe
évidemment de l'animal à l'homme et
également de l'homme à l'animal et ça se
trouve déjà chez platon b parce que ça
vient de pythagore et que pythagore est
allé voir en inde est donc là il ya un
soubassement
métaphysique ontologique spirituel
religieux je pense que en occident le
véganisme ne s'appuie pas complètement
sur 7 sur cette transcendance est une
espèce d'immanence qui est une immense
de morale moralisatrice qui consiste à
dire il faut être doux il faut être
tendre il faut gentil faut pas faire il
faut être gentil il faut pas faire de
mal aux bêtes faut pas me faire de mal
aux plantes faut pas me faire de mal à à
la terre il faut pas faire de mal à à
l'air il faut pas faire de mal à l'eau
était temps on s'excuse ça reste très
judéo chrétien on s'excuse d'exister
parce que évidemment de temps en temps
quand on parle on aimait du gaz
carbonique qui ont contribué au trou de
la chaudanne la couche d'ozone et star
donc il ya une espèce de d'éthique de la
compassion généralisée qui est pour moi
non pas une exacerbation
de l'idéologie hindouiste mais une
exacerbation d'un certain type de
catholicisme c'est à dire là le
catholicisme d'un saint françois
d'assise qui parle aux oiseaux qui c'est
jérôme qui qui est en compagnie du lion
pas une espèce d'harmonie d'ailleurs le
pape en fait ses choux gras aujourd'hui
mais par l'harmonie entre l'homme la
nature les animaux en disant il faut
absolument que nous retrouvions une
espèce de sens à notre existence donc il
faut moins manger de viande voir il faut
plus manger de viande du tout qu'elle a
évidemment il ya des radicaux qui estime
qu' il faut il faut évidemment ne plus
manger de viande mais qui veulent ne
sont pas contre le fait d'égorger un
boucher s'il le faut si votre avis sur
les mouvements reagan non non parce que
moi je pense que le le
il faut reprendre les choses un peu plus
en amont parce que un végétarien à tort
parce que quand il pratique son régime
végétarien
s'ils mangent des oeufs du beurre de la
crème du lait etc il rend possible le
meurtre le viol le le l'abattage mais
d'un veau c'est à dire la vache est le
fait du lait pour nourrir son veau si
vous voulez que le lait il donne
d'ailleurs qu'il donne du beurre ils
donnent du fromage mais il va bien
falloir de qu'elle vous a bâti et
leveaux parce que il faut que vous
preniez le lait à la vache et cie la
vache n'a plus le lait pour le veau
leveaux ne vit plus donc voilà pourquoi
nous mangeons du veau donc c'est à dire
que à chaque fois que vous mangez du
beurre vous tue un veau à chaque fois
que vous mangez de la crème à vous tous
et un mot c'est nécessaire les normands
c'est un vrai génocide tout seul non
entre le beurre et la crème bah je ne
vous fais pas dire mais ce que les gens
oublient souvent donc on se dit les
végétariens ne sont pas cohérents mais
les dégâts ne sont plus et si vraiment
vous êtes vegan vous du ballon ça vous
dit non je mange pas justement parce que
les gars savent ça ils savent que si si
vous mangez lait beurre crème etc ben
vous rendez il faut absolument qu'on tue
les animaux les jeunes animaux qui sont
privés de leur propre nourriture
maintenant vous dites bon les vegan ils
sont contre l'exploitation des animaux
mais ils ont souvent une lecture
culturelle de ce qu'est la nature c'est
à dire que très peu savent que qu'une
vache c'est pas un produit naturel c'est
un produit culturel la vache n'existe
pas sans l'homme il existe un au rock
sans l'homme il suffit de regarder les
peintures des cavernes mais le roc a été
dressée croisés c'est à dire qu'on en a
pris alors vous pouvez prendre des
animaux qui donnait du lait d'autres
qu'il tenait de la viande d'autres qui
donnait de la férocité d'autres qui
donnait les chevaux n'a fait la même
chose avec les coups ce le fameux le
cheval primitif d'une certaine manière
le cheval primitif il rend possible
aujourd'hui un pur sang arabe ou un
anglo arabes et l'iran possible en même
temps un cheval de trait ou pour parler
mieux aux gens qu'ils comprendront
peut-être mieux le loup d'origine le nom
d'origine rend possible aussi bien le
doberman que le chihuahua il s'est passé
quoi entre le doberman et le chihuahua
puisque ces chiens de tous petits qui
s'allument suivre et dorothée qui
s'appelle diogène entre le chihuahua et
le doberman qui équivaut comme ça où le
dogue allemand ou ce genre de choses il
y à une même source c'est à dire que les
animaux les 2 2 les poules les vaches
les cochons et terrain n'existe pas
autrement qu'après la domestication des
hommes donc il ya des phacochères et des
sangliers mais ya pas de porc le port
c'est du dressage c'est un travail
culturel sont des siècles d'agriculture
qui ont rendu sa le paysage c'est la
même chose le paysage sauf dans des
endroits qui sont restés totalement
sauvage mais quand on est devant la
nature et constituerait bell etc mais
tout ça a été façonnée et les hommes on
taille et coupées et monde est planté
ils ont fait tout un travail qui est au
bout des siècles rend possible ce genre
de paysage donc le végal fallu le
végétarien à tort parce que ils
occasionnent quand même la mort des
animaux le vega n'a plus raison que le
végétarien mais en même temps quand ils
disent bah voilà un plus de chevaux de
course plus d'animaux de cirque je suis
assez d'accord avec ça moi j'ai honte de
voir des ours des lions dans des cages
par exemple ou des otaries habillés
comme des petits garçons des choses
comme ça enfin c'est moi j'ai eu honte
pour les hommes donc suis pas contre le
fait que comme en finisse avec sa part
dont
vous avez des gens qui j'ai perdu mais
j'ai gardé mon sang de sjow qui ils
veulent éviter par exemple les courses
de lévriers ils veulent éviter les
animaux domestiques et on se dit mais
effectivement vous avez un chat chez
vous le chat ils étaient fabriqués pour
être un animal domestique ça va il ya
une heure son truc il y avait un
problème maintenant disons libère tous
ces animaux là les gars ne veulent
libérer les animaux donc est ce qu'on
fait on ouvre dans les écuries on ouvre
les pores qui ont dit aux chevaux à
l'isie dans les fermes on dit allez on
ouvre les bretons les bols les brebis
les moutons et non pas les bretons et
mutti mais les vaches les volets cochons
les poules on dit allez hop on libère
ces animaux mais c'est tout de suite la
nature qui va prendre le dessus c'est à
dire que vos boules et vont se trouver
bouffer par les renards ils vont pas
durer très longtemps vos animaux etc je
rentre pas dans les détails mais les
animaux redevienne à ce moment là des
prédateurs et sont problématiques pour
l'homme donc cette idée de libérer les
animaux est une fiction entrepôts
centres et c'est à dire on a
l'impression que les animaux en cage
sont des hommes en cage et c'est toute
la logique de l' éternel treblinka enfin
de tous ces gens qui nous disent que les
abattoirs serge 8 c'est que c'est
exactement la même chose où il abat
civile stinger non c'est pas la même
chose c'est pas la même chose moi si je
dois sauver 1 on dit voilà vous avez un
animal et puis vous avez un juif il va
falloir que vous puissiez sauver lingots
12 ans ne vous n'avez le droit d'en
sauver qu'un seule j'ai pas dire
j'hésite je ne vais pas dire j'hésite il
faut être casuistes et les gens qui nous
disent que c'est la même chose moyens il
n'y a pas de problème c'est que je dis
c'est clair on va sacrifier deux chiens
j'ai eu l'idée de dire mais non c'est
exactement la même chose et puis en même
temps les vegans se trompe sur des sur
leurs lectures du monde parce que leur
nature et culturelles et qu'elle n'est
pas naturel si vous vous intéressez un
peu aux plantes aux arbres et on est en
train de le faire et c'est tant mieux
vous avez des gens qui travaillent sur
la neurophysiologie végétales et vous
dit bonne plante des fleurs il ya une
tige est dédé il ya des feuilles qui
capte la photosynthèse enfin les gens
font ces colonnes ces soldats puis
déraciner un radis c'est l'été et on a
mesuré l'activité électrique qui se
passe dans les racines dans les
radicelles et dans les réseaux toutes
ces choses là et bien les plantes sont
en interaction avec le monde c'est à
dire les plantes souffrent elles aussi
de sorte que l'argument des vegan qui
nous disent il faut pas manger d'animaux
risque que les animaux souffrent est un
bon argument mais il faut et
faut dire que les plantes les végétaux
souffre aussi on le sait très bien j'ai
beaucoup utilisé cette image en ai parlé
dans un ex appel cosmos mais les arbres
communiquent par exemple il ya des
endroits où on avait un enclos un grand
espace mme avec des acacias et il y
avait des impalas les impalas venaient
manger les corses des acacias il était
donc l'existence des acacias en péril
les acacias ont dégagé des molécules
olfactives sont des gaz particulier ces
molécules olfactives ont été perçus par
les autres acacias qui eux mêmes ont
réagi en dégageant une substance toxique
qui a fait que quand les impalas manger
leur leur écorce et bien les amis
l'amour est c'est à dire que un arbre
était capable de comprendre qu'il était
en danger il a donc été capable de
transmettre une information qui était
attention les autres il y à du danger
des animaux vous mettre en péril alors
les shows de la chose n'est pas
forcément dit ainsi mais le manier le
message qui passe c'est ça on dégage les
acacias dégage une molécule qui fait de
telle sorte que ce qui était dangereux
disparaît et on tue les les impalas
quand les impalas sont tués les arbres
comprennent qu'ils peuvent reprendre
leur configuration j'allais dire presque
ontologique précédente et à ce moment là
il n'en voit plus les molécules de sorte
que les impalas peuvent à nouveau les
brouter mais en moins grande quantité
donc leur existence n'est pas en péril
on ne me dira pas qu'il n'y a pas là
quelque chose qui ressemble à de
l'intelligence à de la mémoire à de
l'émission de messages à de la
transmission de messages à de la
souffrance à de la conscience de ce que
peut être la mort la disparition puis
donc très bien d'avoir imaginé que les
animaux étaient doués de conscience de
mémoire d' intelligence etc j'y souscris
mais encore un effort pour considérer
que tout ce qui est vivant et
susceptible
oui je dirai tout ce qui est vivant et
susceptibles de cette même logique
on pourrait on pourrait disserter sur le
véganisme si on l'a
la conscience animale longtemps on va
bifurquer un peu vous êtes
souverainistes comme un souverainiste
perçoit l'immigration
l'immigration est laide elle est
inévitable
ce n'est pas pensable de figer la
société en disant voilà on a un état un
pays une nation et puis les gens qui
sont là ne vont pas bouger et ils vont
rester dans leur village et ils n'iront
pas dans les villes et ne bougeront pas
nous sommes dynamiques ici on fait une
histoire de l'humanité moi j'aime bien
opposées à la moraline de notre époque
des gens c'est bien c'est pas bien la
généalogie de nietzsche en disant mais
qu'est ce que sait d'où ça vient comment
ça marche j'ai fait mon arbre
généalogique de manière génétique ça
peut se faire ça se fait pas en france
n'a pas droit mais j'ai fait un petit
écouvillon un petit coup découvrions
dans votre jeu vous envoyer puis on vous
envoie une carte et on vous dit voilà
d'où vous venez et tout le monde vient
de la côte est de l'afrique et il ya des
passages divers et multiples et on voit
ce qu'on était les déplacements des
peuples dont nous provenons chacun les
uns les autres donc évidemment le
principe de la migration est un principe
consubstantielle à l'humanité
c'est donc un c'est donc indispensable
maintenant qu'ils bougent quand et
comment et de quelle manière on imagine
bien que quand il ya une immigration par
exemple en europe avec les moyens qui
étaient sud de l'europe avant le train
avant l'avion avant la voiture et les
gens avancer au pas d'un homme ou
avancés au trot d'un cheval ou pas d'un
cheval
on voit bien que les mélanges se faisait
mais que c'était pas les mêmes pouvait
avoir des invasions fameuse invasion 10
microns qu'on compte qu'on disait
barbare moi par exemple je
suis un descendant de danois ça fait dix
siècles que ma famille étant est en
normandie mais le ja ont froid le danois
qui la met en scène ses adhérents froid
et on ferait qui sont avec guillaume le
conquérant à la bataille d'hastings est
donc évidemment il ya une descente de
cette population qui vient d'afrique qui
est arrivé du danemark qui s'est
installé en normandie en ce qui me
concerne on y trouve depuis depuis dix
siècles et alors ça c'est pas des
quartiers de noblesse pour autant je dis
simplement que quand il ya eu des
déplacements de gens qui relevait de la
même zone alors après
rapprochons nous dans l'histoire disons
que ces zones dont nous parlons tout à
l'heure dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure la zone judéo chrétienne il est
déjà là et comme n'est que je pense dans
la logique du judéo-christianisme vous
avez effectivement des mélanges qui se
font mais pour le coup avec les polak
comme on disait les polonais avec les
les italiens ou avec les porte
aus les portugais qui venait et qui
venaient travailler par exemple en
normandie a vu une ce qu'on appelait la
smn société métallurgique de normandie
avait des hauts fourneaux il y avait une
trentaine de population mais c'était une
c'était un mélange qui se faisait avec
des gens qui relevait de la mère
spirituelle judéo chrétienne donc après
tout il était blanc il était judéo
chrétien et jésus marie joseph il avait
ça en commun même s'il venait de porto
demande espagne en europe portugal s'il
venait de madrid ou s'il y avait un
certain type d'immigration puis après
cette immigration cette immigration elle
s'est faite de manière planétaire avec
alors la décolonisation il y avait un
moment donné où on ne prend 7 en termes
d'empyr enfin où il ya eu des empires et
eu la fin des empires donc il ya eu un
empire anglais empire allemand il ya une
empire français etc je rappelle
d'ailleurs que l'on mitterrandie la
nationalisme c'est la guerre il a tort
la première guerre mondiale c'est une
guerre non pas entre des nations et
entre des empires et on voit bien qu'à
la fin de la guerre 14-18 ce sont des
disparitions d'empyr qui ont lieu ne
sont pas des disparitions de sont pas
des disparitions de donation et donc la
décolonisation et le fait que vous avez
des gens qui commencent à bouger qui
traversent la méditerranée pour le coup
qui ne mélange pas des peuples ou des
races mais qui mélange des cultures et
des religions est donc là pour le coup
c'est autre chose donc il c'est pas la
même chose d'avoir une immigration
ullman d'avoir une nomination
énumération hindouiste d'avoir une
numération confucéenne bouddhistes
hindouistes animistes ou et c'est donc
là pour le coup ce qui était mélange un
terreau civilisationnel
passe à autre chose et pour le coup on
est dans des mélanges cosmopolite et
planétaire c'est un autre cas de figure
si les civilisations sont fortes et
puissantes il n'y a aucun problème on
peut imaginer que après tout on a la
france c'est une espèce de règles de vie
ce sont des principes c'est c'est la
laïcité de montaigne c'est la pensée que
la pensée de descartes la pensée
cartésienne si l'ironie de voltaire
c'est le marivaudage de marivaux c'est
la pensée positive d'auguste compte au
19e siècle c'est l'engagement libertaire
de camus au xxème siècle je veux dire
c'est l'égalité c'est légué la
fraternité liberté égalité fraternité
laïcité féminisme on est tous assez très
européen donc elle tout ce qui est judéo
chrétien a rendu ça possible déclaration
des droits de l'homme ce qui était amour
du prochain jadis devient fraternité ce
qui était libre arbitre devient liberté
le libre arbitre la genèse c'est le
fruit défendu je préfère ce que vous
voulez mais si vous faites ceci ou cela
il va se passer sous silence mais vous
avez un libre arbitre c'est pas la même
chose qu'avec l'islam qui nous dit qu'on
n'a pas de libre arbitre la fraternité
c'est de dire eh ben voilà la fraternité
tous les hommes sains parce qu'ils sont
chrétiens et on en a une que les ja
c'est à dire l'église de la planète et
on s'aime parce que on est chrétien et
il ya plus heureux et amoureux données
saint-paul d'il ya plus d'hommes ya plus
de femmes les plus de mètres il ya plus
d'esclaves il ya plus de propriétaires
de riches de pauvres etc c'est ça ça
donne par la suite la fraternité avec la
révolution française l'égalité la
fraternité donc on voit bien que il y à
rien un passage c'est même pas un
tuilage devenu un passage entre les
vertus spirituelles transcendante de la
religion chrétienne et puis les vertus
immanente moral je dirais morale et
politique de la révolution française et
que c'est un tout que le la pensée
grecque infuse la pensée romaine mais
que la pensée gréco-romaine infused à
pensée judéo chrétienne et que la pensée
religions judéo-chrétiennes elle seule
elle fabrique aussi la laïcité qui est
émancipation de ses propres pensées
jusqu'à ce que la révolution française
pose les bases de quelque chose de
nouveau donc là la france c'est pas tout
sauf la révolution française où c'est
pas la révolution française sourc ce qui
précède c'est tout ça et donc il ya un
moment donné où cette civilisation elle
suppose une règle du jeu et où vous avez
eu des migrants qui disait le moi j'aime
cette règle du jeu je viens en france et
j'ai envie de jouer envie d'être
français donc on se moque de la couleur
de peau de la religion c'est une
religion personnelles et privées on a le
droit de ne pas boire d'alcool de ne pas
beau de ne pas manger de porc parce
qu'on est musulman mais en fait ça chez
soi et puis voilà et on estime que la
république c'est bien la france c'est
bien la règle du jeu ne sommes nous
convient il s'est récemment il a
évidemment aucun problème et puis à un
moment donné où il ya une immigration
qui pour le coup se fait problématique
avec des gens mais pas tout le monde par
exemple n'y a pas de problème avec
l'immigration chinoise avec
l'immigration vietnamiennes avec
l'immigration asiatique s'est pas
exactement la compte donc on a le nez
des problèmes les plus importants on en
a pardon s'écouler comme quoi comme
problème c'est la bessée l'impossibilité
de fabriquer une communauté qui serait
une communauté nationale une communauté
qui dirait on aime la france on est on
aime la france et les français on aime
les vertus de la france la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité la laïcité et le
féminisme c'est de dire non même pas ça
nous ne sommes pas là on n'aime pas la
liberté on aime la soumission c'est le
principe de l'islam on n'aime pas
l'égalité des peuples supérieur des
peuples inférieurs enfin des religions
pas des peuples pardon des religions
inférieur et des peuples supérieur il ya
là c'est clairement dit dans le coran
vous avez les religions de lui après les
infidèles et les mécréants mais dans les
religions du livre avec une hiérarchie
vous êtes les meilleurs une sourate du
coran et puis après on a le
christianisme puis après on a les juifs
puis après on a les mécréants les
infidèles donc ça c'est pas l'égalité et
quant à la fraternité il ya une
fraternité qui est celle de l'oumma de
la communauté et qui est une fraternité
qui ne concerne que la communauté c'est
à dire que exactement comme avec les
juifs tu ne tueras pas mais si tu peut
massacrer tous les cananéens ça ne pose
aucun problème tu vas là une
contradiction non ya pas de
contradiction ce sont juste des morales
qui ne sont pas universels quand les
christianistes dit tu ne tueras pas je
défends pas le christianisme midi quand
le christianisme parce que il a beaucoup
trop quand ils en avaient les moyens
mais quand le christianisme dit tu ne
tueras pas il dis pas tu ne tueras pas
les chrétiens et tu ne tueras pas un
absolu quand les juifs disent tu ne
tueras point et qui dit tu peux y aller
avec les canadiens où que les musulmans
disent tu ne tueras point mais en même
temps tu peux les gorges les juifs on se
dit il ya une contradiction qua non ya
pas de contradiction il ya cette idée
que l'on mette une communauté supérieur
à l'universel alors est ce que l'on veut
que la louma soit une communauté
supérieur à l'universel et c est ce que
on veut que les femmes soient
inférieures aux hommes et que la laïcité
ne soit plus une vertu par exemple donc
j'ai dit la règle du jeu occidental
c'était sa liberté égalité fraternité
laïcité féminisme tout ce qu'ils disent
mais moi je suis très bien ici chez vous
non en revanche la règle l'aïe ne me
convient pas ni liberté ni égalité ni
fraternité ni les cités du féminisme en
nous disant de manière très subtile
évidemment que les femmes qui se
soumettent à leur mari et qui qui qui
consentent par exemple aux
qualifications je pense à orillia
bouteldja qui nous dit c'est ça être
féministe se soumettre au patriarcat on
s'est dit ah ben c'est quand même pas
exactement ce que ce que nous a dit
simone de beauvoir
donc effectivement il ya eu d
immigration qui était intérieur rouge et
du christianisme il ya eu d immigration
qui ont été planétaire mais pas
problématique du tout et puis d
immigration qui sont devenus
problématiques avec un vrai problème
parce que le vrai problème il est pas la
couleur de peau il n'est pas la religion
puisque je dit tout à l'heure que vous
pouvez être asiatiques et exposer les
problèmes témoigne c'était c'est le
problème de la de la lecture de la
guerre d'algérie cette idée que
ignorer le bien d'un côté le mal de
l'autre qui aux rudesses à l'opie des
héros que etc etc et c'est une lecture
de la delà de la guerre d'algérie qui
est une lecture totalement légendaire me
suis allé en algérie pour aller sur les
traces d'albert camus quand j'ai fait un
livre sur albert camus j'ai regardé les
informations elle est là j'ai tout
compris je me dis mais effectivement le
journal est un journal de propagande qui
estiment que la guerre entre les
français et les algériens existe
toujours avec les bons et les méchants
avec et état c'est pas du tout ce qui se
passe pourquoi ça se passe comme ça
pourquoi on entretient cette mythologie
parce que c'est un masque pendant qu'on
laisse pendant qu'on dit voilà l'ennemi
c'est le blanc c'est le français et que
leleu le président de la république
vient se faire soigner en france
d'ailleurs on ne dit pas ce qui se passe
c'est à dire la souffrance du peuple
algérien la souffrance du peuple
algérien pendant qu'une mafia qui est
issu du ml du fln dispose du pétrole du
gaz et et vit une vie d'une vie de 2,2
de richard enfin ce sont des gens qui
viennent une belle vie et qui exploitent
leurs peuples mais il est bien évident
que pour cacher la vérité de ce qui se
passe en algérie il vaut mieux expliqué
que le responsable la responsabilité
c'est pas la mafia issus du fln ce qui
est la responsabilité c'est la france
qu'il l'est depuis toujours responsable
coupable monster et comme c'est le
discours officiel de l'algérie et c'est
un discours mythologiques et qu' une
partie des présidents de la république
reprennent ce discours en disant oui on
vous présente nos excuses on n'aurait
pas dit du et cetera terrain ni le
meurtre des harkis général de gaulle
quel et ahmed général de gaulle y
dix ans 62 vous avez votre autonomie ben
maintenant vous avez votre autonomie
suis plus m'occuper de vos affaires pas
dire vous êtes autonome vous avez votre
indépendance mais je continue à
m'occuper d'eux des histoires dit
maintenant c'est votre affaire donc le
massacre des harkis c'est pas le général
de gaulle général de widi maintenant
vous êtes autonome vous êtes souvent
chez vous moi je m'occupe plus de deux
de vos affaires donc il ya une écriture
de l'histoire qui est une écriture
mythologiques mais c'est souvent comme
ça que ça fonctionne et je pense que le
travail du philosophe c2d mythologie
c'est de dire faisons véritablement de
l'histoire il n'ya pas des n'y a
pas des héros il ya eu par exemple des
massacres dans des villages comme ça
mais nous a par exemple les massacres
ont été faits par le fln contre l'est
ménal mouvement nationaliste algérien
tout ça pour qu'il y ait une domination
de de l'inde du fln sur le mouvement
autonomiste et indépendantiste
donc il faut vraiment faire de la de
l'histoire et je comprends que des des
gamins paumés qui jadis avait des
informations par l'homme parle par le
canal satellitaire puis aujourd'hui avec
internet sont branchés sur les
télévisions d'algérie
crois qu'effectivement la légende qu'on
leur présente c'est la vérité c'est un
petit peu comme si on dit aujourd'hui
que par exemple la télévision chinoise
est libre ou que la télévision russe et
libre que la télévision türk est libre
tout le monde va dire laissez moi rire
françaises libres non bien sûr que non
on n'est pas libre non bien sûr que non
et donc je comprends que dès que des
jeunes soient paumé reprennent le
discours quitte un discours d'un
discours de légende un discours de
mythologie parce qu'ils ne font pas
d'histoire mais faisons vraiment
l'histoire de la guerre nager la guerre
d'algérie aujourd'hui c'est le monopole
de benjamin stora qui guide qui discours
qui qui délivre le discours officiel il
a le monopole du discours sur la guerre
d'algérie or vous savez que la vérité de
la guerre d'algérie ça donne des récits
historiques si ces récits historiques
sont des récits légendaires légende et
mythologiques il est bien évident que
vous dites n'importe quoi sur l'histoire
revenons à l'immigration
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand ya des
milliers de réfugiés qui débarque sur
nous coûte parce que victimes de la
guerre victimes de la traite des
esclaves victimes de tout un tas de
saloperies qu'est ce qu'on fait
les accueils on les accueille pas alors
ah ben là vous vous posez une bonne
question qui est la question pragmatique
c'est concrètement on fait quoi ici et
maintenant ici et maintenant les
accueillent mais on accueille pendant
dix ans maintenant venez vous êtes chez
vous en vous proposent nos poubelles
notre sous d'autoroute nombreux tels des
nombreux tels des changes la de nos
échanges heure où vous allez pouvoir
dormir sous les ponts vous allez pouvoir
squatter des immeubles en déshérence ça
s'appelle ça la france ça s'appelle la
france ça s'appelle l'hospitalité
française on peut pas dire d'un côté je
vous en prie venez vous êtes comme chez
vous et puis en même temps les laisser
vivre en déshérence moi je vois des
gamins sous mes fenêtres là qui je me
dis mais ces enfants enfin une vingtaine
d'années si on leur propose rien de
désirable on ne propose pas d'apprendre
la langue leur propose pas d'apprendre
la culture on ne propose pas de trouver
un travail ne propose pas de les
intégrer il ya aussi des immigrés de
l'intérieur ce que si on vient je vous
emmène dans mon village natal à chambois
vous avez aussi des gens qui lisent mais
nous nous on n'a pas de on n'a pas de
boulot personne ne s'occupe de nous
personne ne veut de nous donner d'argent
il ya des milliards qui sont déversées
sur les banlieues y en a jamais pour
faire de telle sorte que par exemple
chambois mon village natal et bien vous
pouvez vous avez des zones blanches le
téléphone portable ne passe pas et les
gamins la i10 bennoo et on fait quoi
pour nous autres états donc je pense
qu'il faut une vaste politique dont dans
un premier temps d'accueil
répondre concrètement à votre question
mais dans un deuxième temps on se donne
les moyens de l'accueil vous dit pas des
gens j'invite tout l'immeuble à venir
manger chez moi et puis les gens
viennent chez vous vous dites j'ai juste
des nouilles mais j'ai des nouvelles
pour 3 et j'ai invité 50 personnes tout
le monde comprendra que ce n'est pas
possible ou pensable alors c'est bien il
ya des idéalistes qui nous et non pas du
tout l'hospitalité etc il ya des
conditions à l'hospitalité c'est pas le
spi qualité j'accepte tout le monde
quelle que soit l'occasion les
circonstances et ses îles ça se
construit une hospitalité ça se
construit la désirabilité de la france
ou de l'occident si effectivement la
france ne s'aiment pas qu'un président
de la république dit que on est moins
que rien qu'on est que vichy et qu'on
est que que que le colonialisme qu'on
est que pet un con et que des
conte etc mais on vous prend au mot bien
sûr la france est détestable ça fait des
années que vous nous en prenons nous
apprenait qu'elle est détestable donc il
faut changer de politique là pour le
coup on est dans le pragmatique
immédiatement on reçoit mais si on
reçoit on accueille si on n'a pas les
moyens d'accueillir on reçoit pas ça
veut dire que dans ces cas là il faut
une politique africaine il faut une
politique islamique c'est à dire que moi
j'ai dit très vite et très tôt que
j'étais contre le fait que la turquie
puisse devenir un pays de l'europe n'a
aucun sens sauf à croire que l'europe
c'est un grand marché alors à ce moment
là effectivement israël le maroc il en
était question à l'époque pourraient
faire partie de l'europe ça veut plus
rien dire
heureusement qu'à une époque il faut
compter avec l'orgueil turc et ils ont
raison d'avoir cet orgueil mais les
choses avec poutine déjà il ya eu une
querelle entre les occidentalistes et
les slaves au filet chez des russes par
exemple les occidentalistes des il faut
regarder vers l'ouest et les slaves aux
phillies et pas du tout on n'a pas
besoin d'aller chercher la vérité de la
russie à paris on a une vérité cela
s'est plutôt de ce côté là qu'il faut
aller voir le triomphe de lénine est un
triomphe occidentaliste lénine il est
marxiste et quand il est marxiste il va
chercher sa vérité à iéna ou à berlin et
puis il y les ramène ça en russie tout
ce qu'il a chez dostoïevski sur la
question ou sur la question de musique
de tourgueniev par exemple dans père et
fils sur les nihilistes avec bazar offre
tout ça montre comme comment les
slavophile les analystes se battre c'est
la même chose avec la turquie atatürk et
puis il ya des gens qui étaient plutôt
alors là atatürk était occidentaliste on
dira et puis ce qui n'était pas un qui
était plutôt pour une spécificité
musulmane tradis neil et ça c'est
combattu un certain temps pendant
atatürk était clair c'était violence des
brutales mais c'était laïque et c'était
occidentaliste il ya sept ce sens de la
fierté d'erdogan est aussi bien erdogan
que poutine ont proposé un temps de
faire une autre robe que l'europe de
marché lors du fric l'europe de l'argent
c'est à dire de faire une europe qui ne
soit pas américaine et il n'y a pas eu
un grand chef d'état qui aurait été
capable de dire banco allons-y faisons
de cette grande europe de l'atlantique à
l'oural jeu reprendre l'expression du
général où cette europe qui aurait dit
mais une europe n'est pas close n'est
pas fermée il ya des ya des points de
jonction la turquie est un grand point
de jonction il suffisait de dire allez
pas qu'erdogan écoutez vous ne serez pas
le dernier des européens vous serez le
premier d'un bloc qui va fédérer les
islam et vous pouvez le faire vous avez
une tradition kémaliste vous avez la
possibilité on vous en donne là la
puissance parce que je veux les turcs
n'aime pas beaucoup les meilleurs jeux
dire qu'ils sont tous les deux musulmans
mais ils sont dans des ans des relations
de conflits qualité et on voit bien
d'ailleurs je vous demandais ne pas dire
que les problèmes sont plus importants
avec la communauté maghrébine qu'avec la
communauté turque en france justement
parce que ce qui fait problème le point
le point d'inflexion c'est cette lecture
de la guerre d'alger je ferme ma
parenthèse et de dire après à erdogan
c'est votre boulot on va travailler
vraiment partenariat vous n'allez pas
travailler en partenariat avec la france
mais avec l'europe et une europe étendue
jusqu'à jusqu'à celle de poutine jusqu'à
l'oural et de dire allez avoue mais on
va vous aider de fédérer la totalité d
islam qui depuis ont disparu c'est à
dire y avait l'islam laïc de
la limite de l'âme de l'irak mais aussi
de la libye d'une certaine manière de la
syrie également il y avait à jouer un
rôle avec il y avait laissé un rôle à
jouer à israël pour régler justement le
problème palestinien dans cette
configuration là les territoires
palestiniens auraient pu être justement
intégré dans cette espèce d'arc
méditerranéen et d'une certaine manière
le nord de la mort de l'europe de
tradition judéo-chrétienne aurait pu
entretenir une relation avec le sud de
la méditerranée qui aurait été justement
maghrébine mais qui aurait pu être aussi
passionnant maghrébine ça peut être
super sub sahariens c'est à dire que
plutôt que de dire l'immigration est
pour vous êtes content se dire mais
comment peut-on gérer des flux régler
des flux à partir du moment où on a des
états on peut négocier avec des états
moi je veux bien que saddam hussein a
été d un nouvel adolf hitler
maintenant y'a t'il y avait-il plus de
morts dans chaque journée de l'irak à
l'époque de saddam hussein
qu'aujourd'hui
la même chose avec kadhafi je pense que
des pays de tradition laïque au les
femmes pouvaient conduire ne pas avoir
de voile aller à l'école faire partie de
la garde présidentielle etc etc c'est
pas exactement la même chose que des
désirs de grains saurait d islam
politique qui pour le coup ne sont pas
démocratiques qui pour le coup ne sont
pas républicains que pour le coup ne
sont pas laïques donc il fallait
envisager donc je vous répond
concrètement il faut à accueillir mais
autant qu'on peut accueillir rendre
possible d accueil qui soit digne de ce
nom c'est pas accueillir des gens que de
leur dire prenez place sous un pont et
ce sera formidable vous verrez la france
c'est ça ça ne fait pas mieux pour gérer
de la délinquance de de la haine ddd
incivillités comme on dis aujourd'hui où
des massacres outre des radicalisations
je pense qu'il y avait un travail à
faire quand on était chef de l'état ça a
été un peu le cas de sarkozy qui avait
fait un discours formidable suivie
d'aucun effet mais qui avait été
effectivement ce discours de l'europe du
nord est puis du sud de la méditerranée
nord de la méditerranée sud de la
méditerranée en disant il faut
absolument que nous entretenons des
relations qui vont permettre des
collaborations qui nous permettrait
plutôt que de mettre de l'argent dans un
assistanat extrêmement coûteux en france
2 tient mieux la faire on va mettre de
l'argent dans votre pays on va vous y
serez assisté dans votre pays parce que
tous ces médecins qui viennent
travailler en france c'est formidable
pour nous on a fait on a fait le
nécessaire vous avez les médecins de la
communauté européenne ils sont payés
d'une certaine manière et puis ceux qui
viennent de l'afrique sont payés moins
cher donc dans les hôpitaux on va
chercher des africains qui sont payés
des médecins africains qui sont payés
moins cher payé moins cher mais en même
temps que deviennent ces pays là et non
plus d'hôpitaux donc on attendra d'eux
c'est une espèce de néocolonialisme que
cette façon de pratiquer l'immigration
c'est à dire 10 go tous vos talents on
voulait prend et puis tous vos talents
on va les mettre sous nos ponts on va
les mettre sous des piles de d'autoroute
et puis on va être des gens formidables
parce qu'on vous accueille même temps on
est en train de massacrer un peuple et
puis on est en train de massacrer les
autres peuples c'est à dire 10 mais que
deviennent ces villages ces pays et on
s'étonne que d'un seul coup l'islam
puisse arriver surgir au mali en disant
mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça
marchait moi je suis allé au mali et une
époque évoque un problème maintenant on
y va plus mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
mais ces deux on à paupériser le mali on
a fait venir plein de maliens le mali
est devenu pauvrissime on a continué à
exploiter à exploiter les sous-sols
justement pour avoir les matériaux rares
qui nous permettent aujourd'hui de faire
des voitures prétendument écologique sur
les voitures hybrides qui fonctionnent
aujourd'hui à l'électricité fonctionne à
l'électricité nucléaire et quand elles
ne fonctionnent pas l'électricité
nucléaire elle utilise des métaux rares
qui eux mêmes sont prélevés dans en
afrique et voilà pourquoi on est au mali
on n'est pas là bas parce qu'on aime
tellement la liberté que quand les
préserve de du jihadisme on s'en fout du
jihadisme là bas on veut juste pouvoir
exploiter avoir des bases et pouvoir
exploiter le sous-sol des africains
parce que la france est tellement
islamophobe fibre perdre islamophile de
manière intérieur qu'elle est
islamophobe sur la totalité de la
planète y'a rien de formidable l'islam
en france mais lors des compos tabasser
des afghans dès qu'on peut tu as bal cd
irakien dès qu'on peut tabasser des
libanais et des libyens dès qu'on peut
tabasser des palestiniens dès qu'on peut
tabasser des maliens alors là il ya
aucun problème on peut y aller on fait
des bombes ont fait des bonds au fond
des tapis de bombes et voilà cinq ou six
millions de gens sont morts de musulmans
sont morts dans les frappes occidentales
pour quelle raison parce que on vend des
armes complexe militaro-industriel
possibilité pour les gens qui fabriquent
des bombes des avions à réaction et
c'est le dire il n'y a pas de problème
et après on fait quoi quand on a fait
beaucoup d'argent on finance les d'état
américain qui eux-mêmes finance ces
guerres qui tournent des bières
islamophobe seger islamophobe génère le
terrorisme terrorisme il tombe pas du
ciel voilà des gens à qui on a dit vous
aviez un pays vous aviez un chef ce chef
c'était adolf hitler ont détruit votre
pays et en même temps on installe la
terreur au quotidien que font ces gens
là ils arrivent en occident ils ont
perdu leur famille ils ont perdu des
membres de leur famille ils ont perdu
leur boulot leur dignité leur pouvoir
d'achat leur langue leur culture leurs
traditions leur nourriture ils ont perdu
tout ça ce sont comme des animaux en
cage et on leur dit voilà vous êtes vous
avez la liberté ils sont là et c'est un
dirigeant qui deviennent paumé et qui
peuvent se faire en doctrine et par
l'islam politique parce que d'un seul
coup c'est un horizon parce que c'est
une hypothèse si on vous dit mais vous
vivez dans un endroit qui vous détestent
ils sont tous racistes votre pays vous
n'y êtes plus vous n'y allez pas vous ni
retourner pas que vous faites quoi mais
vous avez un pays qui s'appelle l'islam
votre pays c'est l'islam c'est lou m'a
donc tu penses que tant qu'on n'aura pas
une politique nationale une politique
européenne une politique planétaire et
mondial c'est à dire tant qu'on n'aura
pas de projets qui ne soient pas des
projets d'argent de fric en disant à
l'isie circulaient ces formidables clown
admis des migrants ici plus on peut on
peut baisser les salaires évidemment on
est des gens ils viennent du mali ils
n'ont pas de papiers ils viennent dire
moi si vous voulez je vous fait la
plonge on leur a dit d'accord pas de
problème tu fais la plongée mais en même
temps pas de papiers pas de trucs tu
donnes appliquer un petit peu d'argent
pas de retraite pas de sécurité sociale
les sans-papiers trouve des petits
boulots comme ça et en même temps
quelqu'un qui arrive qui dit mais non le
moi je veux un salaire je veux des
vacances veut une retraite tandis qu est
ce que vous imaginez donc si vous ne
voulez pas ce boulot là un lien de 200
qui attendent là donc l'immigration
telle qu'elle est pratiquée aujourd'hui
elle fait le jeu du capitalisme
planétaire c'est formidable
l'immigration et c'est pas étonnant si
le medef et pour ce il a le droit
libéral la gauche libérale sont pour et
qu'en même temps on dit venez venez
venez ça fait une main d'oeuvre pas
chère du tout en même temps vous humilie
on vous exploite on vous méprise on va
vous mettre dans des cages à lapins on
va laisser vos gamins dans les caves il
va falloir faire du trafic de haschisch
pour vie de cocaïne de drogue etc et
puis on ferme les yeux là-dessus
territoires perdus de la république
aucun problème tout ça rend possible le
business ça rend possible business
l'immigration est une chose qu'on ne
doit pas laisser aller en disant venez
quand vous donné puisqu'on sait très
bien que dans ces cas là c'est la loi de
la jungle l'immigration c'est quelque
chose qui doit être voulu en train
d'état entre un continent donc la france
l'europe et puis entre d'autres pays
avec lequel on passe des accords de
coopération il faut qu'ils aient des
universités au mali il faut qu'ils aient
des hôpitaux au mali il faut que et des
routes des autoroutes il faut qu'ils
aient des centrales électriques il faut
qu'ils aient des possibilités d'avoir
jeu parfois des garages des voitures des
des écoles etc tant qu'on ne pensera
l'immigration qu'en terme de ces biens
l'immigration ou c'est pas bien vous
êtes pour ou vous êtes content vous êtes
pour vous êtes formidables vous êtes
content d'être que marine le pen vous
êtes un solo non la question
d'immigration c'est là qu'elle quand
pourquoi à quoi sert cette émigration
aujourd'hui pourquoi fait-elle le jeu du
grand capital pourquoi est-ce qu
effectivement ça permet de détruire le
code du travail pourquoi ça permet de
détruire les salaires pourquoi ça permet
de détruire les retraites parce qu'on a
une main d'oeuvre qui est taillable et
corvéable à merci
delors d or quand on parle aujourd'hui
de la traite des esclaves c'est
formidable d'aller chercher des poux
dans la tête des gens en disant mais une
traite des esclaves la 114 192 ouais
d'accord très bien mais il y
actuellement une traite des esclaves
quand on quand on laisse passer tous ces
migrants disant venez venez venez à
installer vous voulez il ya toujours une
toile de tente ici il ya un bout de
square là il ya un endroit où vous allez
pouvoir vous mettre à l'abri si puis
voilà appui débrouillez vous pour le
reste tout ça c'est formidable moi
j'appelle ça de la traite esclavagiste
et j'estime que si on ne pense pas
l'immigration ce que j'ai essayé de
faire un peu rapidement si on ne pense
pas des solutions la question inévitable
de l'immigration bien sûr il ya toujours
il y en aura toujours et on n'arrête pas
l'immigration remettant les gens à la
mer comme étant jean sur des bateaux en
les renvoyant chez eux ça n'a aucun sens
c'est la thèse de l'extrême droite c'est
pas la mienne mais c'est juste de dire
quelle politique de l'immigration
pouvons-nous avoir qui serait une
politique de civilisation ni on est en
train de détruire les civilisations moi
j'adore l'art africain je collectionne
un peu d'art africain je suis curieux de
ces civilisations là que sont elles
devenues que sont elles devenues une
civilisation c'est quoi pour ces gens là
on a détruit leurs peuples le revendre
leurs coutumes leur façon de s'habiller
ils sont tous avec des nike des machins
des téléphones portables et arrondis
mais c'est ça que vous voulez un grand
marché planétaire avec des gamins qui
sont des consuméristes des gamins pour
lesquels le l'horizon indépassable c'est
le grand magasin dans lequel on peut
acheter le supermarché dans lequel on
passe des choses des objets eh bien avec
lesquels on pouvoir frimer mon tracteur
etc mais mais mais quand vous regardez
la sagesse africaine et on l'a pillé on
l'a massacrée c'était une sagesse
extraordinaire sagesse panthéiste de
rapport à la nature autant aux éléments
à la nuit au jour aux étoiles moi j'ai
adoré en mauritanie entendre des
compteurs me racontait des choses alors
que on avait l'impression sur le toit
d'une maison qu'il suffisait de tendre
le bras pour décrocher des étoiles et on
se dit mais quand on fait de la
civilisation malienne mauritanienne ah
bah quand il s'agit d'avoir trois
statues au quai branly c'est formidable
les arts africains les au premier ça
c'est formidable mais quand il s'agit de
dire qu'avez vous fait de ces
civilisations que vous continuez de
détruire l'immigration sauvage et
libérale comme elle est pratiquée est un
génocide de civilisation on tue des
civilisations mais le grand marché
planétaire qui veut un gouvernement
planétaire et qui ne veut que des
individus qui consomment quels que
soient leur religion leur couleur de
peau a intérêt à dire traverser la
méditerranée pas de problème venez chez
nous vous allez vider nos poubelles vous
allez utiliser les services sociaux vous
allez vous entre vous entassés dans des
cages d'immeubles où ça va sentir les
urines de chiens de chats de piste de 2
du main mais ce genre de jours du zénith
c'est ça qu'on vous propose vous allez
vivre ici c'est très bien vous allez
voir avec des dealers qui font régner la
loi dit que c'est ça qu'on veut c'est
pas l'idée que je me fais de la france
n'est pas libre non plus que je me fais
de l'hospitalité pas être pragmatique on
fait quoi avec les problèmes de
l'immigration qui ont été générés depuis
les trente à quarante dernières années
nos d'intégration
repli identitaire qu'est ce qu'on fait
on arrive on tend la main on fait quoi
j'ai posé souvent la question à des gens
qui qui effectivement fond de
l'immigration un problème majeur pour
moi c'est pas un problème majeur je
réponds à votre question bien volontiers
mais je pense que c'est pas encore tard
danger pour nous non plus n'est pas
improbable je sais bien c'est bien mais
le vrai problème majeur c'est là c'est
la disparition des pensées historique
c'est la pensée la disparation de la
culture si vous ne savez pas lire écrire
compter penser plus rien n'est possible
plus rien n'est possible donc évidemment
vous allez me dire bah ouais mais bon
elle est arrivée au pouvoir vous êtes
chef de l'état veut dire allez on va
recommencer la méthode syllabique ocp et
puis on va régler le problème du non
droit dans les banlieues je pense que ça
marchera pas ce qu'ils nous disent alors
je puis en parler avec eric zemmour par
exemple faites quoi vous voilà c'est
tout bois mais dans les bateaux les
renvoie chez eux logiciels sont ils sont
nés là donc j'ai de cela ils fantasment
l'algérie n'ayant jamais mis les pieds
donc vous dites ou même s'il était né
ici dans un quartier éventuellement ton
père est né là aussi dans ce quartier
c'est ton grand père qui est né dans un
bled en algérie t'as jamais mis les
pieds là bas on va pas te renvoyer dans
un pays qui n'est pas le tien
le pays qui est le tien et est nulle
part c'est aussi ça le problème il
fantasme un pays qui est celui de leurs
ancêtres ils fantasment une france qui
n'existe pas plus parce que finalement
ils ne savent pas ce qu'elle est et ne
connaissent pas l'histoire de france est
une une mode r pas les jugements parce
qu'ils sont dans cette idée que c'est
bien c'est pas bien et on ne pense plus
la subtilité des choses donc évidemment
il ya la solution du on reprend les
quartiers les uns après les autres avec
l'armée la police la justice les
éducateurs les psychologues les
thérapies hop on fait un carré un
quartier puis un autre quartier plein
doute sur tille je crois pas à ça non
plus évidemment pas pensable je ne vois
pas comment on peut résoudre
concrètement ce genre de problème sans
que une deux trois générations
le permettent mais je suis pas optimiste
au point de dire on va pouvoir en
faisant sa une génération une deuxième
génération mais ça va continuer à se
dégrader pendant ce temps là alors ma
réponse à votre question est claire je
ne tourne pas autour du pot moi je suis
un tragique je pense que c'est fini je
pense juste que c'est fini et que à
votre question c'est un peu la question
que vous pouvez me poser en disant mais
bon voilà le titanic vient de percuter
l'iceberg il ya une voie d'eau qui est
extraordinaire et on fait quoi
maintenant ben voilà il ya des gens qui
disent on met les canaux et puis on s'en
va c'est plein de gens qui plein de
jeunes aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas au
canada encore aux états unis en parant
d'australie en parrain nouvelle zélande
mais on quitte ce navire parce qu'il est
pourri vous avez ceux qui disent ça on
va mettre des on va colmater des trucs
les marine le pen ou les mélenchon dont
genre mais non l'un des rustines il ya
aucun problème on veut mettre de la
rustine on est des rustines grosse comme
ça la voie d'eau est grosse comme
l'amazon que la maison mais nous on fera
ceci on fera cela et c'est ça marche pas
théorie des mots d'eric zemmour ça
marche pas non plus je prends simplement
qui à un moment donné une hostie bas il
reste plus que l'élégance quoi c'est à
dire que quand tu continues
quand il ya eu le naufrage du titanic
les gens se sont se sont tapés dessus ce
sont roués de coups se sont volés se
sont massacrés ce sont piétinés ce soit
et c'est alta de toute façon quoique
vous fassiez le bateau va couler le
bateau est en train de call il va couler
et ne nous reste plus qu'une solution je
dirais baudelairienne du genre la
décadence ne passera pas par moi la
barbarie ne passera pas par moi je serai
résistants ça sert à rien d'être
résistant mais ça sert pour l'élégance
ça sert pour l'élégance en disant ça ne
passera pas par moi le fait que vous
vouliez louer les utérus des femmes
pauvres et acheter des embryons
d'enfants en continuant à vous dire de
gauche si vous voulez je n'empêche qu'à
pas ça parce que ces grands projets
transhumanistes mais je suis contre je
résiste je me rebelle je suis du côté
des utérus des femmes pauvres je suis du
côté des enfants sans père je connais
les enfants sans père et je dirais un
jour qui quoi comment de quelle manière
et état de manière très pragmatique ma
mère et de l'assistance publique elle
n'a eu ni père ni mère d'autres
personnes près de moi après deux mois
ont eu des pères qui n'étaient pas les
pères des géniteurs qui est certes et à
d'autres enfants qui me sont très
proches qui ont un géniteur qui
s'étirait qui a disparu et qui est
et qui est tellement présent par son
absence depuis depuis ça je suis pas un
défenseur de la famille catholique du
genre papa une maman je digère pas ce
qu'il faut qu' il est un père qui ramène
les sous à la maison pendant que la
femme fait la cuisine pendant qu'il est
en train de rentrer je pense pas dans
ces termes là j'ai dit simplement que
quand le père n'est pas l'âme
il y à une souffrance quoi qu'on dise il
ya une souffrance et en a beau être
adoptée je connais aussi une autre
personne qui a perdu qui a été
abandonnée qui a été adopté par des gens
extraordinaires il se fait que les gens
extraordinaires ne compte pour rien en
face de la souffrance de 2,2 de ce père
absent de cette méconnaissance du père
donc je parle d'expérience en disant qu
effectivement quand il ya un trou dans
l'être c'est peut-être de ne pas se
constituer donc voilà pourquoi je
devrais pas une question dont j'ai
oublié qu'elle était parce que le
principe ici oui
on bifurque c'était sur l'immigration
les solutions de migration vous êtes
pragmatique vous gardez l'élégance jeu
pour mai sur le film et les garçons
étaient sur la sur l'un sur la question
d'élégance et je disais de fait que je
prenais l'exemple de la procréation
médicalement assistée en disant je
n'empêcherai pas de la gestation pour
autrui pardon c'est pas du tout la même
chose de la gestation pour autrui que je
n'empêche que pas que ça ait lieu
puisque de toute façon il faut
marchandises est il faut marchandises et
les utérus marchandises et les embryons
batou marchandises et est d'ailleurs
pierre bergé le disait s'il fut il
suffit de voilà bien vers l'elysée
renvoie une femme qui est en train de
line caissière et le lou s'est musclé
son travail pourquoi il y aurait pas son
utérus quoi ah oui effectivement on peut
aussi louer son rectum on peut aussi
louer son agent ça s'appelle de la
prostitution et puis dira après tout
c'est pas plus problématique autre chose
si je pense qu' il vaut mieux un
prostitué certaines parties de son corps
et pas d'autres quoi et donc je me
posais à ça en disant ce n'est pas
possible ce n'est pas pensable que ça
puisse être
réalisable or ce sera réalisé donc je
peux très bien dire ce que disait
voltaire c'était mon prof de philo en
terminale qui disait voltaire des il
faut cultiver son jardin pourrait se
dire bon moi je fais plus rien ce n'est
plus rien à faire de toute façon le
monde va à vau-l'eau que je parle je
parle pas ce sera la même chose je
m'occupe de moi cigarettes whisky
petites pépées jouissance personnelle
hédonisme trivia les consuméristes et
puis ça ira très bien j'attends la mort
comme ça non je pense qu'il ya quelque
chose de chevaleresque à dire on se
rebelle ça n'est pas possible ça n'est
pas pensable ce n'est pas acceptable on
reste debout ça va couler on va mourir
on est dans le bateau il coule mais les
trucs qu'on fait des trucs qu'on fait
pas ça s'appelle de l'élégance quoi
qu'est-ce qui vous ce qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui serait tellement insupportable
pour vous
qui vous pousserait à vous opposer
frontalement
comme les stores l'appel à la prière en
france en bretagne est ce que ça
pourrait vous énervez ça
non parce que
parce que j'ai encore une fois je suis
un pragmatique et à dire que quand vous
avez des théoriciens de la 2 de la loi
de 1905 et ils vous disent qu'il ya des
choses qui est gravé dans le marbre
c'est la loi de 1905 ah oui enfin il ya
une loi qui disait que les faiseuses
d'anges elle était et est passible de la
peine de mort et comme renvoyer
certaines à la guillotine il se fait
aujourd'hui que l'effeuilleuse d'ange ne
s'appelle plus des faiseuses d'anges
mais des médecins qui pratiquent lives
et j'ai qui est remboursé par la
sécurité sociale bon ça a changé je dire
entre entre le les avorteuse que sous
pétain on envoie à la mort et puis
aujourd'hui les médecins dont c'est le
métier et qui pratique un acte remboursé
par la sécu les deux accès à bouger ça
bougeait pas ce que la société a bougé
et donc la société a bougé en 1957 loi
lieu il s'agit de s'opposer au monopole
du christianisme le monopole du
christianisme il est dans les hôpitaux
des noms le rapport au corps et là c'est
à dire que vous si vous souffrez ça
s'appelle le péché originel donc on va
pas travailler sur les opiacés sur les
sur ce qui va diminuer votre douleur
votre souffrance vous êtes une femme
vous avait avorté vous avez couché voilà
d'abord c'est pas bien puisque vous tuez
un an un enfant mais vous êtes
éventuellement une fille-mère donc c'est
encore moins bien parce que vous avez
couché en dehors du mariage donc on va
faire souffrir et ses instables et vous
payez c'est bien fait pour vous bon
c'était le monopole dans l'école où il y
avait l'école laïque bien sûr mais aussi
des écoles religieuses en faisait le
catéchisme et les gamins dans mon
village je suis dans 59 les gammas qu'à
l'époque catéchisme
entre les wise as lu
donc évidemment on à changer de
civilisation le catholicisme
christianisme poser problème le judaïsme
n'opposait plus depuis que le problème a
été réglé avec napoléon et l'islam ne
posait aucun mal puisqu'ils n'avaient
pas d'islam il y avait un islam et ils
étaient dans des pays musulmans qui
étaient des pays de dominer par la
france 20 colonisés par la france et
c'était un islam assez tolérant
globalement oui on mange pas de porc on
buvait pas d'alcool mais en même temps
parler aux juifs il y avait une espèce
de 2,2 de facilité à exister il y avait
une espèce d'orientalisme on accepter ça
et on pouvait en algérie être musulman
on n'a jamais persécuté un musulman
parce qu'il était musulman et la
république accepter ce genre de choses
même si en même temps elle accepté que
ces citoyens c'est des citoyens de
seconde zone je ne suis pas dupe de ce
genre de choses donc la loi qui est à
contextualiser comme tout d'ailleurs est
à contextualiser la loi est à
contextualiser et ce contexte est
modifié donc on peut faire on est c'est
pas compliqué on peut faire deux choses
soit on est dans l'éthique de conviction
soit né dans l'éthique de responsabilité
éthique de conviction vous dites moi je
suis contre les prières de rue donc si à
brest il ya un appel aux prières de rue
je suis con point à la ligne je veux pas
le savoir c'est ainsi et j'emmène les
gens voient les flics et là où du bon
d'accord mais ces gens qui prient dans
la rue qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'ils
vont arrêter de prier et vous allez
faire qu'est-ce qu'ils vont penser de
vous et de la république il va se passer
quoi là donc ça ne peut pas faire ça ou
l'autre qui dit éthique de
responsabilité pas de problème on laisse
faire éthique de huy de leurs
responsabilités ça existe on laisse
faire on laisse tout faire moi je pense
que nous souffrons de sa l'éthique de
conviction c'est souvent la gauche qui
n'a pas l'éthique de responsabilité
l'éthique de responsabilité c'est
souvent la droite qui n'a pas l'éthique
de conviction pour le dire autrement
l'éthique la gauche a des idées mais
même si ça marche pas et les fidèle à
ses idées la gauche a n'a pas d'idée et
les pragmatiques pourvu que ça marche la
droite pardon tu avais raison c'était
juste pour voir si vous écoutiez non non
je plaisante mais ce qu'il faut obtenir
c'est qu'effectivement c'est ce que je
souhaite ce qu'on souhaite avec stéphane
simon un front populaire c'est de dire
mais prenons à la gauche qu'elle a mieux
son éthique de conviction et prenons à
la droite ce qu'elle a de mieux c'est
son éthique de responsabilité ça donne
quoi sur une question comme la vôtre ça
donne que
il y a en france et ainsi on a laissé
faire des gens qui se disent tout à
l'heure que on a jeté d un certain
nombre de personnes dans les bras de
l'islamisme de l'islam politique qu'il
faut distinguer l'islam l'islamisme
d'islam politique le problème n'est pas
l'islam le problème est l'islam
politique c'est pas du tout la même
chose et donc on se dit après tout prié
à genoux dans la rue ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas de mosquée et donc si on veut
arrêter les prenez les prières dans la
rue ben en fait que les prières dans les
mosquées maintenant les mosquées c'est
pas compliqué que ça coûte de l'argent
alors soit on est un faux cul et
aujourd'hui on subventionne la
construction d'une mosquée sous prétexte
que c'est culturel alors qu'on sait très
bien que c'est cultuel et à ce moment là
tout le monde ferme les yeux donc on dit
bah oui l'argent public va servir à
construire une mosquée et je vois dans
ses pas ne pas dénoncer des endroits que
je connais bien mais je vais pas créer
des polémiques mais il ya déjà des
villes que je connais bien dans lesquels
on subventionne sous prétexte de culture
des lieux dont tout le monde sait qu'ils
ne sont pas des lieux culturels mais des
lieux cultuels alors après on peut dire
oui mais après ils font des mange
ensemble et au cur du jeune et ses
terrasses et culturels oui d'accord
m'enfin bon il n'empêche que on sait
très bien moi je suis contre cette
hypocrisie et judy si on laisse faire
c'est pas compliqué on va laisser faire
les salafistes on va laisser faire des
gens qui vont dire mais non on va faire
une quête et cette quête elle va rendre
possible des donations qui viendront du
qatar de l'arabie saoudite ou du yémen
deux pays qui sont intégristes et qui
ont intérêt à dire je paye mais en même
temps je paye pas parce que j'aime
l'islam je paye pas ce que je veux
pouvoir mettre mon grain de sel dans
cette aventure et on va choisir les
imams et on aura des prêches qui seront
des prêches salafistes est ce que c'est
ça qu'on veut éthique de conviction et
en fait comme s'il n'y avait rien du
tout et puis on aimait bien l'éthique de
responsabilité fait qu' il existe cet
islam et il faut donc qu'ils soient
républicains qu'ils soient dans le cadre
républicain souvent je dis alors vous
êtes pour ou contre le voile jeudi mais
moi mon rôle c'est parce qu'il ya sur la
tête ce qu'il ya dans la tête je connais
des gens qui ont un voile sur la tête et
qui sont des républicains mais ça ne me
pose aucun problème et je connais des
gens qui n'ont pas de voile sur la tête
et qui ne sont pas des républicains ils
sont musulmans mais pas du tout des
républicains donc c'est plutôt là qu'est
le problème donc je pense que si des
gens prient dans la rue c'est parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de lieu pour prier et
s'ils ont des lieux pour prier alors à
ce moment là effectivement il
seront pas dans les rues ils pourront
prier et la république peut très bien à
ce moment-là dire eh bien on va
travailler avec vous la religion est
incompressible on va pas dire on
supprime la religion est ce que ça a
donné en union soviétique pendant des
années puis d'un seul coup l'union
soviétique flanche ça devient la russie
pas d'un seul coup le pouvoir des pop on
voit que le clergé orthodoxe est là qu
il était là depuis toujours et c'est
donc on peut pas moi je pense qu'on peut
lutter contre les croyances religieuses
avec de la raison avec du débat avec de
la contextualisation avec de la
théologie et de l apostrophe à théologie
mais qu' on ne lutte en disant vous
voulez prier dans la rue a pas de
prières de rue ça donc je suis contre
cette interdiction à la suis pour le
fait que alors ça s'appelle pas des
aménagements raisonnables mais ça
s'appelle une prise en considération de
ce que sont les gens en disant eh bien
nous allons pouvoir construire des
mosquées mais en même temps on va
regarder ce qui s'y passe et vous en
conviendrez nous sommes en france il
n'est pas question que vous puissiez
prêcher la haine de la france des
français au sol en deux choses les
secteurs la même chose avec l'école si
vous voulez je suis pour les écoles
libres - mais pas seulement pour les
écoles confessionnelles mais quand les
écoles libres les écoles
confessionnelles vous dites écoles
coraniques écoles l'école juive
certainement mais on pourrait aussi dire
mais après tout moi je suis libertaire
j'adore la ruche de sébastien faure par
exemple les expériences de pédagogie
libertaire eau libre aux enfants de
summerhill ou oudot d'autres experts ou
évidemment les maria montessori où les
célestin freinet parce que c'est devenu
mais ce que ce que ce que les textes
disent et à ce moment là vous dites et
bien voilà on peut créer une école etc
pour moi être pro données en ce sens ces
défendre c'est défendre la liberté ici
donc la liberté ne consiste pas à dire
je suis contre la religion j'interdis la
religion interdit les manifestations
religieuses je suis pour le fait qu'on
puisse dire eh ben non toutes les
manifestations religieuses sont
possibles ou pensable dans les limites
de la loi elles sont encadrées par la
république et vous conviendrez qu'il
vaut mieux un imam qui fait des études
de théologie qui parlent correctement le
français qui connaissent éventuellement
la culture française en même temps que
sa culture parce que c'est aussi
important de connaître sa culture il
suffit pas juste de dire je suis imam
pour un la ligne il faut vraiment
connaître le corps est pas dans le salon
mode y est comme ça et je trouve normal
que par exemple on puisse faire passer
des exemples plus dire moi je monte dans
un avion parce que je sais que le pilote
il a passé un examen qui se piloter un
avion et quand je me fais opérer de
l'appendicite
je sais que le chirurgien c'est à passer
un examen et qu'ils peuvent opérer et
bien j'estime que on doit pouvoir énorme
enseignante sûrs et que pense la même
chose il a passé des examens olitique
pardon il le politique
alors le politique moi je pense que le
politique c'est le peuple et que
jadis beaucoup dit que mon père était
ouvrier agricole il est à lui peu de
temps à l'école mais il a appris à lire
à écrire et compter à penser à aimer la
poésie la littérature etc à ne jamais
faire d'erreur de raisonnement de
démonstration à connaître la géographie
de son pays à ne jamais dire une sottise
je n'ai jamais surpris à dire une
sottise je ne parle pas de son éducation
morale qui était impeccable on va
arrêter un genre de saint laïc et je me
dis mais l'école a rendu ça possible
c'est à dire que ce septet était
possible et est pensable qu'on puisse
apprendre ce genre de ce genre de choses
je re dit moi votre question sur les
politiques s creed qui passent un examen
à la brède politique et donc ce peuple
là quand on le sollicite et il avait
deux choses derrière lui il avait cette
éducation dont je viens de vous parler
dès que je parle de mon père je parle
trop logé par trop loin mais cette
éducation que l'école lui donner mais en
même temps une éducation empirique que
la nature lui donner c'est à dire mon
père il était dans ce village de
chambois donc la nuit le jour les
saisons les cycles le fonctionnement de
la nature le nom des plans des oiseaux
des arbres c'est à il savait toutes ces
choses là et quand vous êtes de
tempérament virgilien je dirais c'est à
dire que vous êtes un contemporain de
virgile et que les géorgiques pour vous
ce n'est pas un grand poème c'est ce que
vous vivez au quotidien vous avez ce que
rouelles après la plaie la common
decency le sens commun le bon sens d'une
certaine manière et le peuple avait du
bon sens quand il avait cette sagesse
empirique obtenu au contact de la nature
doublé de la culture que la république
lui enseigner à l'école et à ce moment
là quand on sollicite et le peuple on
avait des avis intelligent le peuple a
changé évidemment puisque aujourd'hui il
n'apprend plus grand chose dans la
nature il souvent urbain plutôt crural
il ne connaît pas elle ne connaît pas
les cycles de la nature il ne connaît
que l'électricité c'est quand même un
truc sidérant l'électricité tout le
monde la connaît personne n'est capable
de dire il a inventé
c'est joseph swan et une ce type il
invente un changement de civilisation
c'est à dire qu'en temps normal vous
aviez les cycles qui vous apprenait des
choses il y avait les solstices et des
équinoxes vous viviez en relation avec
ça et puis aujourd'hui non vie ont vu
rythme d'électricité c'est à dire vous
allumez vous était il ya l'électricité à
volonté de la lumière à volonté la
lumière a des effets sur notre cerveau
on sait très bien et donc quand le jour
est très court et que la nuit est très
longue l'hiver ou quand l'été la nuit
est très courte et que le jour est très
long le métabolisme n'est pas le même
c'est d'une bêtise une cote les alley
recours l été et les allocs oui enfin
n'aura chacun aura compris il fait
longtemps nuit l'hiver et mais peu jour
et l'été il fait longtemps jour est peu
et de nuit ça produisait des effets sur
un métabolisme et puis quand on voyait
les faisait un potager et bien envoyé le
temps si vous avez vous dire j'ai arrosé
mais meradi alors allemands n'ont rien
dit alors les radis chaque chose en son
temps la nature va apporter ce qu'elle
leur a apporté dans le temps qui sera
celui de la nature et puis vous voyez
les fleurs les feuilles les fruits et
puis les feuilles qui tombent et puis
voilà que ça recommence etc vous
intégriez le fait que vous étiez vivant
et que vous étiez une petite partie d'un
grand tout c'était le peuple d'avant les
chansons de jean ferrat sur les gens qui
quittaient les montagnes pour allait
descendre dans le roman il ya du formica
et du ciné donc aujourd'hui on a
effectivement un peuple qui n'a plus à
et ce savoir républicain et ce savoir
enseigner par la nature et qui en plus à
l'espèce de bouillie pour ne pas dire un
mot plus grossier mais dans la tête que
la télévision les médias les radios de
les réseaux sociaux dit m donc on dit
mais n'importe qui dit n'importe quoi
parce que tout le monde ment et que tout
le monde dit tout et n'importe quoi la
grande question que vous posez c'est la
question de condorcet et condorcet
disait avoir vu une personne une voix
très bien fait bon c'est plus compliqué
que ça il y avait des familles les
le régime censitaire d'état mais on doit
être informé voilà pourquoi je fais de
l'éducation populaire et pourquoi j'ai
fait autant de l'université populaire
pourquoi front populaire continue
reprendre le contrôle électrique
que quoi que l'on confère d'éducation
populaire non c'est juste pour dire je
vous donne les moyens de penser
librement si vous êtes donc de reprendre
le contrôle de la directive c'est pas de
le contrôle de la dialectique c'est de
donner à l'autre et moyens de la
politique ce n'est pas de contrôler
c'est juste de lui dire quand vous serez
citoyens vous allez voter mais si vous
êtes sous informés vous allez voter
n'importe quoi et si vous êtes mal
informé vous allez voter n'importe quoi
et si en plus de ça vous êtes idéologisé
vous allez voter n'importe quoi si en
revanche en amont on vous explique plein
de choses et que vous disposez de plein
d'outils alors là peut être que plus
finement vous allez pouvoir exercer
votre votre droit de vote est donc
aujourd'hui souvent le dya le peuple
vous idéalisez le peuple etc sinon là
encore je fais de la généalogie je vous
dis qu'est ce que le peuple quand où
comment de quelle manière aujourd'hui on
a fabriqué une populace et l on a
transformé une grande partie du peuple
en population j'ai dit souvent que le
peuple c'est cette c'est une entité
c'est une puissance dotée d'un doté
d'une raison une intelligence c'est pas
c'est pas une foule acéphale lugg qui
n'a pas de tête
la masse est une foule à ses fans et la
masse et des fabriques et
quotidiennement par les médias dominants
par la radio dominante par l'école avec
les enseignements dominant ce genre de
masse selon gustave le bon
le gie des foules oui mais le bon dit
des choses très justes il fait de la
sociologie aussi alors il ya plein de
choses chez gustave le bon mais dans la
psychologie des foules il le dit
effectivement que la masse n'est pas la
somme des individus qui la constituent
tenez vous pouvez mettre 100 personnes
qui seront intelligente cultivée et ses
1 100 personnes en intelligente et
cultivée ensemble ça fait une foule qui
n'est pas 100 fois plus cultivé qu'il
foule de gens qui ne seraient pas
cultivé il dit la foule s'est toujours
une foule les masses sont toujours des
masses et elles obéissent à autre chose
que cas la raison à l'intelligence à les
déductions à la réflexion etc et il a
raison dans ce sens il ne dis juste que
il ya une espèce de tropisme animal qui
fait que quand on est quand on
expérimente la puissance de la de la
totalité ont des résonne au sens
étymologique c'est à dire la raison ne
fonctionne plus moi je crois en théorie
des trois cerveaux même si on dit
qu'elle est métaphorique et qu'elle
n'est pas très juste mais cette idée
qu'ils eurent un cortex fans et au
cortex cortex et cerveau reptilien je
pense qu'il ya des moments où on est
branché on débranche quand je dis oui
c'est l'inconscient auxquelles je crois
qu'il n'est pas l'inconscient freudien
mais à des moments où vous apercevez
qu'il ya des dangers et vous vous
apercevez que des gens vous met en péril
je sais pas vous êtes de briand
dialectiquement vous ne faites une
réponse et gégé monsieur je me sens dans
l'embarras je sais pas comment il aida
secoue ta qu'on déconnecte et c'est le
cerveau du serpent qui arrive et on va
trouver un truc on va être pervers on va
on va mordre on va être long on va se
défendre quoi et il ya des moments où
quand vous quand on vous renvoie une
image de vous même vous vous êtes vous
avez fait un truc pas bien et on vous
dit vous avez fait ce truc pas bien on
vous a vu vous allez voler etc et vous
ne renonce pas moi non c'est pas moi il
ya des photos il vous faut voir les
photos c'est pas moi mais il ya des
vidéos regardées c'est vous et la
casquette c'est là vous avez le choix de
bermudas c'est vous non c'est pas moi
parce qu'à un moment donné deux claques
on a verrouillé cerveau le cortex le
néocortex et on a donné les pleins
pouvoirs à la hausse et vaut rien je
crois que la foule des branches le
cortex des branches la raison et quelle
branche le cerveau reptilien verse une
espèce de reptile ondulant la foule et
si vous avez un type qui fait le cerveau
de du ddt de la foule ça suffit on y va
on y va et toc et tout bon parent il ya
deux ou trois qui sont qui sont les
espèces de tête de foule est qui et qui
peuvent faire faire faire à la foule des
choses terribles et on voit bien comment
hitler par exemple mussolini enfin tous
et où
staline qui ont été des gens qui à la
tête des foules étaient capables de
sculpter manier les foules et là c'est
un peu ce qu'on reproche souvent gustave
le bon sens forcément l'avoir lu gustave
lebon dit ça et on dit après abba ça
veut dire qu'il défend sa non il dit
juste que les lois de la foule séquelles
déconnecte et que quelqu'un peut
reconnecter et que ce devient
effectivement le dictateur qui lui est
capable de conduire c'est pour ça qu'on
a reproché avec un populaire
les journalistes vous empochez de
fédérer cette foule informe cette masse
informe ses 5 îles en fait peur
c'est un objet faudra d'extension et par
extension peut-être politiquement
parlant après vous êtes menaçant pour
des partis politiques parce que vous
serez capable de fédérer la foule en
forme
c'est un objet fantasmatique qui a été
critiquée jeudi tout à l'heure de moi
quand vous demander de ne présenter que
je fais la part de l'old bailey
fantasmatique de ma réalité je sais que
il ya plein de gens qui fantasment
puisque je suis et je dis moi je sais
que c'est pas moi donc appris peuvent
dire ce qu'ils veulent ce qu'ils veulent
que je sois doriot déat moi je sais qui
je suis aucun problème si bhl pense que
je suis jeune doriot le jeu le plein
dedans d'être là mais voilà front
populaire a été fontas mais pendant un
mois et demi on a fait savoir avec
stéphane qu'ont annoncé s'être vu un
vagabond c'est quoi la vie bah c'est une
revue qui va fédérer les souverainistes
de droite virgule de gauche
virgule d'ailleurs virgule de nulle part
c'est pas exactement la même chose que
fédérer les centristes de droite et de
gauche ce cas là on oublie de nulle part
et d'ailleurs et c'est s est nulle part
et ailleurs qui ne nous intéressaient et
d'ailleurs pour ce que j'en sais ils
sont plutôt de nulle part et d'ailleurs
et de droite et de gauche ils sont
minoritaires quand on donne dix mille
noms et que on voit les abonnés de de
ménard par exemple venant de ménard etc
libé le monde dise abbas a surtout
séduit l'extrême droite oui pas de
problème vous avez donné quatre noms sur
10000 ça fait 0 0 4 % de gens dont il
faudrait dire qu'ils sont d'extrême
droite va leur disant de monarques et
d'extrême droite et d'alain de benoist
et c'est d'accord très bien c'est ça
surtout 0,04 donc on voit bien qu'on n'a
pas fait des régimes par amalgame pardon
stratagème pas en main c'est ça parce
qu'on a fantasmé sur cette idée et on a
supprimé le d'ailleurs et de nulle part
on garde de droite et de gauche qu'on
supprime de gauche et puis on dit de
droite est en fait c'est surtout
d'extrême droite du monde d'accord dans
ces cas là si vous pensez ça vous avez
le droit de penser sable de la même
manière que vous me fantasmée que je ne
suis pas ce fantasme vous fantasmez
cette revue qui n'est pas le fantasme de
vous signifier on a droit à quatre pages
de saloperies de charlie hebdo personne
n'a vu la revue ils n'ont pas lu la
revue la page de la nationale c'est la
semaine suivante la revue est parue ils
ont saloperie il y avait quoi dans les
quatre pages je n'ai pas lu je lis
jamais ces trucs là mais je veux dire
que john a toujours des amis guide à la
latte à vue ils te traite de machin de
taille de ses doigts ça va je ne lis
jamais la presse kim est consacré ni les
bonnes pas ni les bonnes et mauvaises ne
recense yon où les ou les mauvais
article donc je n'ai pas le détail mais
j'ai des jours les je ne lis pas le
détail mais j'ai toujours des amis qui
me disent que etc semaine suivante ils
ont fait c'est tout à leur honneur à
papier en disant bon on a eu la revue
entre les mains on a lu bon ces
souverainistes icm en correct mais c'est
pas rouge brun s'est pas fasciste comme
on a pu le dire bravo bravo parce que
charlie hebdo n'était pas obligé de dire
qu' il avait suivi la la meute des
journalistes qu'il n'avait pas lu et qu'
ils disaient rien à faire était réglé
donc c'est quand même très honorable de
dire une chose pareille mais ça quand
même fonctionner comme ça alors pourquoi
y at il eu cette espèce de réaction
alors pour le coup là de cerveau
reptilien c'est d'un seul coup ce type
il va fédérer les gens qu'on compte
qu'on s'évertue à ne pas fédérer depuis
si longtemps et là on a quand même un
viatique extraordinaire celle famille le
pen c'est la famille le pen marine le
pen dit noël et le 25 décembre il y bien
sûr que ça peut paraître le 25 décembre
monsieur marine le pen a dit que j'étais
le 25 juin donc le front anti et le
front républicain anti le pénis dira le
25 décembre et le dit le digne du 10
décembre si noël bon d'accord voilà où
on en est à un moment donné où le
problème c'est de savoir est ce que
marine le pen pense à ou pense pas ça
est d'accord et pas d'accord est-ce
qu'elle a raison parce qu'elle est à
tort non elle adore tout le temps donc
dit non elle a raison tout le temps moi
je me fous de marine le pen c'est pas ma
mesure c'est pas ma boussole je veux
juste savoir si le site souverainiste
est une bonne idée je passe savoir si
ces idées de marine le pen et jean luc
mélenchon
6 et la ligue et de marine le pen tant
mieux si c'est celle de mélenchon entend
mieux depuis quelques temps c'est celle
de jean castex depuis quelques temps
c'est aussi celle d'emmanuel mapfre ont
depuis quelques temps c'est également
celle de geoffroy roux de bézieux le
patron du medef formidable ils sont tous
devenus souverainiste donc ce que ce que
j'ai dit c'est que il ya un moment donné
où ce que nous souhaitons stéphane et
moi c'est fédérer tous ces gens qui se
disent on en a marre de la politique
politicienne alors que la politique nous
intéresse les 60% des gens qui ne sont
pas allés voter au président si aux
dernières municipales ne sont pas des
gens qui disent la politique ça nous
intéresse pas ce sont au contraire des
gens qui disent mais ça nous intéresse
mais avec ce que c'est devenu ça ne sert
plus à rien donc nous on a envie de
restaurer le politique dans sa noblesse
en disant mais c'est simple la
démocratie c'est le pouvoir du peuple
par le peuple pour le peuple c'est pas
compliqué c'est ça que fait le général
de gaulle quand il dit je perds
législatives 120 oui dit je me
représente tout ce que fait mitterrand
il reste que fait mitterrand une
deuxième fois il reste que fait chirac
ira est il fondé cohabitation et giscard
avait prévu que s'il perdait les
élections législatives il aurait aussi
lui fait une cohabitation la
cohabitation c'est le début de la fin en
politique c'est à dire c'est le c'est le
règne du chef et de l'autocrate c'est
pas le règne du peuple le général de
gaulle quand 1,69 on lui dit on veut on
veut pas de vous on veut pas de votre
projet sur le référendum concernant le
sénat alors qu'il avait dissout
l'assemblée nationale précédemment et
qu'il avait eu un raz-de-marée que tout
le monde s'en seraient contentés de ce
raz de marée un lui dit non non moi je
veux que le peuple euros 10 si vraiment
il ya toujours ce ce contact entre lui
et moi et évidemment comme la gauche
votre contre votre contrées que la
droite une partie de la droite de votre
compte des gens pas très connu à
l'époque sauf pompidou mais pour puits
d'où votre contre
assez probablement jusqu'à votre
franchement content puisqu'il dit oui
mais chirac tous ces gens là sont donnés
présents dans le public par la suite
donc je pense qu'il ya un moment donné
où la rupture du contrat et les cible
parce que la politique c'est ça le
peuple il ya quelqu'un d'autre jour qui
rend compte en rencontrant malhomme à
macron aux tuileries lui dit vous êtes
mon employé c'était peut-être
inélégamment dit mais tellement juste
cette façon de dire si vous êtes là
c'est parce qu'on vous y amis n'ont pas
forcément moi mais parce que la
souveraineté populaire vous a désigné
dès lors vous n'avez pas des droits sur
moi vous avez des devoirs à mon endroit
ce que nous voulons nous affrontons
muller c'est très exactement ça à dire
le peuple à un désir voulu écouter vous
l'écoutez si marine le pen gagne des
élections européennes
et bien la gagner on dit pas il n'est
pas question qu'elle gagne ce serait une
catastrophe
elle gagne que dit macron finalement
gagné 2,6 peu ça s'appelle perdre c'est
donc moi qui suis vainqueur je suis le
deuxième je suis le vainqueur bon
d'accord très bien ça passe comme une
lettre à la poste il change rien il fait
rien du tout en démocratie on dit elle a
gagné et bien on la nomme on le nomme
premier ministre c ou alors on
démissionne soi même on dit je ne veux
pas qu'elle soit premier ministre je
mets mon mandat de président en jeu je
démissionne on refait des
présidentielles on refait des
législatives dans la foulée et je re
nomme un premier ministre on confirme ce
que vous dites ou on n'infirme il se
passe quoi avec les municipales vanins
vague verte et ben vague verte ils ont
gagné les municipales même s'il 60%
n'ont pas voté sur ceux qui ont voté un
grand nombre ce qui parfois un petit
nombre mais a fait confiance à un écho à
l'écologie ben on dit c'est pas c'est
très clair le message du peuple il est
très clair le peuple veut de l'écologie
donc on trouve un premier ministre
écologiste et on leur dit vous allez
former votre gouvernement c'est pas moi
qui vais m'en occuper et vous allez
trouver à l'intérieur et c est pendant
deux ans vous allez être le premier
ministre écologiste de la france parce
que je suis un président de la
république qui écoutent ce que le peuple
me dis donc dans la mesure où le
président la république n'écoute plus qu
il fait ce qu'il veut que en 2005 le
peuple dit on peut pas du traité
européen en 2007 en 2008 ont eu ni vol
aurait quand même deux fois de suite on
dia macron sur deux ou trois années
d'exercice du pouvoir on veut pas de
vaud mais on veut autre chose autre
chose et qui dit mais non non on
continue il est bien évident qu'il reste
d'actualité de dire le fondement de la
souveraineté en france c'est le peuple
ce que je crois ce que nous croyons à
front populaire et c'est pourquoi tous
ces gens qui à la bergère
enfin tous les autres qui nous ont
traités de tous les noms des gens qui
disent mais laissez donc les experts
faire laisser faire les éditorialistes
éditocrates les journalistes d économie
s'effondrer les financiers les banquiers
tous nos copains qui bricolent des trucs
que les patrons de
des usines à ce montage là enfin et les
sondages nous avait prévenus dont marine
le pen au second tour quand il était
quand il était candidat aux
présidentielles n'ont jamais prévu la
disparition politique de lionel jospin
et les sondeurs sont encore en train de
nous expliquer les choses donc
effectivement on voit bien que ils sont
là parce qu'ils font du fric parce
qu'ils fabriquent l'opinion parce qu'ils
sont possédées par des gens qui ont
intérêt à dire nous avons testé matin
nous avons testé bidule il est là il est
là etc et puis finalement on fabrique
l'opinion sans trop s'en apercevoir
c'est de la pub exactement qu'on fait de
la pub pour des couches culottes on fait
de la pub des hommes politiques en
aidant ma chère et tendre aux marchands
est en baisse on va vous cherchez à
baroin on remonte le barrois en
descendent baroin on monte des filles on
descend de fillon qui à un moment donné
on descend vraiment pas ce qu'on dit
vraiment et puis et puis on remonte du
mélenchon ont fait peur en disant voilà
le mélenchon est à la hausse donc voilà
le mélange jointe à la hausse attention
fascisme de gauge abbas moment là la
remontée du mélange donc obtient la
remontée systématique du mâcon le mag on
est en hausse donc y aura
systématiquement un mélange noir best
seller les instituts de sondages donc
les français ont bien compris que les
instituts de sondage manipulé tout ça
que les journalistes étaient tous
copains comme cochons globalement ils
disent tous la même chose
au bout du compte les gens tous d'y
voter mâcon on a beau dire à l'humanité
dans un communiqué 10 kw à 10 par voter
macro on dit faute et contre le fascisme
qui émaillent le pen donc en gros débat
qu'on bon bah si l'humanité le journal
le plus subventionnées par l'argent
public le figaro le monde tous les
autres journaux disent il faut voter
massivement pour les manuels macron le
candidat du système aujourd'hui ça va on
a compris quoi
je peux plus le mois je quand les décors
les élections sont déjà pliés je ne
dépasse pas moi j'avais près de paris
moi je peux vous donner le je peux vous
dire qu'il sera présent dans la pluie
qui ne joue pas les dix caisses de
champagne
et
comment du bouchon pas dire du bon sinon
c'est pas du champagne mais alors c'est
qui c'est quoi le dit ce sera un
représentant de l'état maastricht
après ça change quoi que ce soit fillon
que je dois m'accrocher que ce soit
sarkozy que ce soit hollande c'est les
mêmes ils font la même politique
question de style on a le lunaire avec
hollande on allait quitter avec sarkozy
on a le psychorigide avec fillon on a le
faux techno le vrai père l'avait que
macron et novella oui on peut dire ça je
pense que c'est vraiment ça
ce qui au bout du compte on dit on va
faire une campagne il reste je peins
combien d'eau avant la campagne qui ont
fait la campagne puis la précampagne et
après on fait des élections internes
puis après on fait des primaires puis
après tu sais on fait des débats qui ont
fait se rencontrer les gens ça fait ça
fait des temps d'audience considérable
ça fait du fric ça fait de la pub ça
fait des annonceurs et puis au bout du
compte marine le pen et leur personne
n'estime qu'il ne doit pas être la
marine le pen donc elle fait partie des
candidats les se seront laissés 500
signatures personne ne porte plainte
contre elle sous prétexte qu'ils
seraient nazis anti démocrate ou
républicaine et c'est jusqu'au bout il
faut qu'elle soit là on fait une photo
qui revient tous les candidats n'appuya
marine le pen ya mélenchon à côté il ya
un fillon il ya macron tout le monde
trouve ça normal puis entre les deux
tours il ya marine le pen c'est bien
marine le pen et là c'est tout ce qu'on
voulait puisque maintenant notre
candidat il est élu le soir du premier
tour donc à fait réglé
nonobstant le fait que macron soient
élues le soir du premier tour il a bien
compris est allé à la coupole fêter tout
ça avec ses copains eh bien on a dit il
est allé pendant les deux tours entre
les deux tours du moins à
oradour-sur-glane puis au musée de la
choir
juste pour dire das reich et adolf
hitler c'est dimanche prochain donc
faites attention un vote et bien moi je
serai juste j'aimerais pas beaucoup
qu'on instrumentalise les six millions
de morts de la shoah pour expliquer que
marine le pen c'est la choix parce que
si marine le pen c'est la joie la joie
c'est pas grave c'est vraiment pas grave
si la shoah c'est grave ce que je pense
alors respectons les morts de la shoah
et arrêtons de dire que c'est
l'équivalent de marine le pen il faut
raison garder elle est fasciste et les
nazis il est anti démocrate et bien
interdisant la interdisons partie
faisant un procès mettons la en prison
mettant en prison les électeurs les les
li temps puis les électeurs puis
expliquons pourquoi et antidémocrates
pourquoi elle est anti républicaine
pourquoi c'est un danger pour la france
pourquoi que les gens comprennent
vraiment simplement les gens les ont
bien compris le mécanisme donc ils
disent moi je reste chez moi je sais
très bien qu'il va être élue la fois
prochaine pourquoi nous détestent à
front populaire alors qu'on existait pas
encore juste parce qu'on a dit non on
joue plus ce jeu là c'est une fiction
votre truc on ne fait plus ne jouent
plus le jeu des élections quand on
laisse croire que un changement de
société comme un changement de
civilisation mais pas du tout mais pas
du tout au bout du compte ce sera ça et
si c'est pas ça il se passe quoi je
risque 12 ans de jurisprudence dit
prince souvenez-vous d'ypres à ce type
il arrive on dit ah avec deux un
mec de gauche antilibérale qui arrive
boire ça c'est quand même vachement bien
moi j'étais très intéressé par ça le
type il arrive chemise ouverte on lui
dit il faut jurer sur la bible dieu moi
je jure pas sur la bible et puis vous
avez vu j'ai pas de cravate en du ca mec
de gauche c'est vraiment un mec de
gauche moi je veux dit j'aurais dit je
ne suis pas croyant vous le savez très
bien or je sais que ce livre est un
livre sacré le sacré de ce livre est
sacré pour moi c'est pas le livre qui
est sacrée c'est le fait qu'il soit
sacré pour nombre de gens donc mon oncle
est décédé il y avait un crucifix dans
un maison j'ai pas mille trucy fille à
la poubelle j'estime et que cet objet
étant sacrée il était sacré du simple
fait qu'il était sacré pas parce que
c'était là la figure du christ parce
qu'il était sacrée pour quelqu'un qui
m'était proche du prince il fait quoi il
fait ça pour laisser croire qu'il est un
homme de gauche bon d'accord très bien
dans la foulée il fallait juste dire
puisque je suis un homme de gauche je
vais faire de telle sorte qu'il y ait un
qui dit un
un cadastre en grèce le cadastre c'est
pas compliqué vous faites des parcelles
et vous dites ça ça appartient à sa à
celui ci ça appartient à celui là tu
sais ça rend possible une clarification
des propriétés de sorte que quand on
sait où est la propriété on sait où et
l'impôt donc on dit vous êtes
propriétaire et bien vous allez payer un
impôt cet impôt il permet quoi l'école
les routes l'infrastructure l'armée la
police l'éducation les universités etc
pas de propriétés pas de propriétaire
pas de propriétaire pas d'impôts pas
d'apport pas d'argent qui rentre dans
les caisses pas d'argent qui rentre dans
les caisses ne pas payer la police m'a
pas payé les enseignants dans saab
hasard total
simplement si on faisait le cadastre on
découvre et quoi que les propriétaires
de la grèce c'est le clergé orthodoxe
mais ledit prince il n'a pas touché à
ses tarifs et le mal en dix ans a pas de
bible mais ça aurait été bien plus malin
de dire moi je le jure sur la bible
parce que elle est sacrée pour beaucoup
de gens et en tant que les a créé elle
est également sacré pour moi d'accord
c'est réglé donc je le fais pas de
problème et je n'insulte personne je ne
méprise personne je ne mens pas je fais
pas un faux serments mais en même temps
dès demain l'homme de gauche que je suis
fier de soi anticlérical etc nous
démarrons ce projet qui fait que dans
les six mois nous aurons un cadastre dès
lors des impôts avec des gens qui feront
de rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses
comme on veut pas toucher aux armateurs
comme on veut pas toucher l'essentiel
des propriétaires le clergé l'essentiel
les progrès depuis les armateurs nadir
on touche à rien
donc si on touche à rien ça sert à rien
d'avoir mis en place ce type en place
après ça l'europe dit mme hamm et ce
type il est un peu toxique est un peu
dangereux il avait 20 ans acquise qui
était un vrai marxiste et on se dit va
ou factices c'est ce type là il est
ingérable autant de l'otan dit price on
pouvait gérer et à ce moment là on a dit
bon écoute et on va essayer de négocier
ce qui est négociable que fait dix
principes de dire non moi je sais ce que
je j'ai été élu pour un projet j'ai un
plan b vous voulez pas de mal et vous
pensez que je j'ai attendu d'être élu
pour que pour découvrir ça je savais
très bien que si celle ci devait être
élu vous seriez contre moi et que vous
commenceriez à spéculer contre la grèce
vous pensez bien que j'ai prévu le truc
j'ai prévu le truc et mes alliés sont et
settat et on dit qui
après ça peut être la russie ça peut
être ça peut être le venez ça peut être
le venezuela où l'amérique du sud au
fait après un travail d'homme politique
une politique qui se disent si je suis
élu il va se passer sa 6e passe sans moi
j'ai prévu ce que je vais faire et j'ai
prévu en faisant ça en disant à l'europe
un nom vous êtes en train de me forcer
le bras et ben non parce que moi j'ai un
projet l'imprévu apprend un plan là on
sort de l'europe mais évidemment comme
de spéculer contre moi j'ai prévu des
alliances et les alliances et le son ici
là ou ailleurs sur ses cartes il sort
juste à ce moment là il ne fait pas ça
il refait un vote en disant vous
confirmer que c'est bien moi vous avez
élu
ah oui c'est bien toi qu'on a élu
évidemment l'europe dit essayer de
refaire un truc en ré seuil est
peut-être sais pas quoi de bricoler les
élections puis des fois on dirait que
non on est pas légitime à ce moment-là
vous reste en place mais vous allez
mener la politique du fmi est à deux
fois il refait le coup deux fois les
dracs lisible oui on a voté pour toi
enfin quand même tout neuf et puis après
il se passe quoi paf le fmi prend la
main et le fmi prend la main l'affairé
réglée la grèce restant ne reste dans
l'europe des filets de l'argent on a
menti les conditions d'entrée de la
grèce en europe ont été falsifiés et on
le sait très bien on a fait tout ce
qu'il fallait avec des banques pour
faire des fausses comptabilité pour que
le pays puisse rentrer dans l'europe on
a laissé faire tout ça moyennant quoi
quand il s'agit de compte la france vote
contre le traité européen en 2005 on lui
dit vous l'avez en 2008 quand la grèce
dit on a dit price on met en place on
lui dit mais il n'y a pas de problème on
va gérer tout ça autrement et vous aurez
quand même le fmi qui va faire la loi
chez vous quand ça se passe au danemark
ont fait revoter pour que c'était un
terrain quand il ya le break citons le
break site on se débrouille pour
attendre attendre attendre attendre en
disant on va voir on va voir on va voir
au revoir il faut qu'ils boris johnson
armand qui disent bon et on y va on été
fait a été élu pour ça on y va donc on
voit bien effectivement qu'il ya des qui
a des yeux il ya une espèce de
résistance
immoral ces gens là ne recule devant
rien une résistance immoral devant les
peuples qui veulent recouvrer leurs
sites leurs lui leur liberté leur
autonomie c'est à dire leur souveraineté
nous on arrive avec une revue qui
consiste à dire nous allons d'un point
de vue g siens réarmer
intellectuellement les souverainistes en
leur disant arrêtez de vous faire avoir
avec tout ce qui vous est racontée par
les intellectuels du système les
journalistes du système les télévisions
les médias du système on va juste faire
une revue dans laquelle on va dire des
choses que vous ne trouverez nulle part
ailleurs parce que nous on n'a pas des
arts n'a pas de nom sera respectée c'est
vous qui êtes les gens qui me proposait
de cette rue pensez bien que quand un
journal est possédée par un type qui lui
possède des trucs dans l'industrie
pharmaceutique dans l'industrie
d'armement dans l'industrie de
l'informatique ou je ne sais quoi il pas
question de faire des enquêtes gênantes
pour l'industrie pharmaceutique
l'industrie de l'armement d'état il
n'est pas question de mettre des
publicités pour certaines boîtes qui
sont des boîtes concurrents qui n'est
pas question d'être donc ce n'était pas
un lieu d'expression de la liberté la
presse quand elle et thomas du capital
comme comme elle l'est actuellement la
presse qui est notre presse qui est
front populaire elle est totalement
libre elle appartient aux gens qui ont
donné de l'argent en disant on est 40
milles on s'abonne au bout d'un an alors
c'est quand je suis chez steam cloud
mais oui c'est là qu'est la cc lacq et
là la vérité ou la liberté de la presse
oui mais vu qu'on est chez nous plein de
choses car haltéro lactée rose pour la
dernière fois par exemple la dernière
personne que j'ai regardé
que votre
nom je ferai pas moi-même chili pardon
frédéric piquionne chine on vous le
conseille vivement oui parce que après
moi je veux un obsédé de l'est du
travail d'écriture je passais
devant pas trop encore mais devant
devant nous devons les écrans c'est
beaucoup pour des informations et des
informations factuelles et ponctuelles
après les voulons formats sont super
super vraiment on peut tout dire on a le
temps de de s'expliquer on a passé cinq
personnes qui sont en train de nous
contredire un journaliste qui a une
oreillette et qui en régie albin le
patron politique à la propagande qui lui
souffle ce qu'il faut dire ce qu'il faut
pas dire le mot qui manque le chiffre a
de quoi je sais qui vous êtes ce que
vous faites cela vous le faites mais il
faut avoir devant soir deux heures par
exemple on se dit eh bien moi je vais
pas au cinéma je parle de théâtre je
passe j'ai besoin d'eux d'heure j'ai
besoin de ça pour travailler et donc
nous attendent en tant que marraine je
regarde parfois je le fais parce que sur
des sujets qui m'intéressent j'arrive
vers vous et sur celui là je me dis à
votre réputation qui vous précède et je
me dis là je sais que je peux y
consacrer du temps parce que
j'apprendrai des choses dans d'autres
endroits n'est pas très sûr on se dit
bon là je vais garder un troupeau de
forme avec quelque chose c'est quand
même c'est un conte minute puis par une
perte des 150000 c'est un peu long quand
je regarde dès le départ un peu étant
donné j mais ça délire complètement
soulagé passé quoi 40 minutes à regarder
quelque chose le type est en train de
raconter que finalement il ya des îles
dont il ya des il ya des soucoupes
volantes et qu'il était parti sur la
mécanique quantique à vous avez déjà dit
des choses très bien sur un écran
mécanique quantique l'autre jour
connaissez vous ce monsieur qui dit des
choses très bien sur la mécanique
quantique et non je regarde je commence
à regarder et là je me dis bon j'ai
perdu du temps quoi donc
question est ce qu'on pensait pas que
souverainisme c'est une glorification
d'un tribalisme archaïque
ça c'est ce que dirait un bhl parce
qu'effectivement tout ce qu'ils nous ont
expliqué que le souverainiste de telle
nationaliste colonna sionisme c'était la
guerre et que un souverainiste et j'ai
eu ça je ne sais combien de fois quand
je suis allé sur les médias
traditionnels et classiques c'est à vous
êtes souverainiste ça veut dire que en
gros vous allez vous vous croyez qu'on
va pouvoir se sortir de tout tout seul
quelle idée vous faites vous du
souverainisme
souverainisme on a besoin d'un virus
d'un d'un vaccin parce qu'il a
coronavirus donc nous on est français ça
va être français et je suis sûr que à
besançon à besançon ou à vesoul on va
trouver le
le vaccin contre l'usurpation enfin
forcément probablement la ville de
fourier la ville d'hugo la ville de
proudhon donc ça pourrait non mais je
dire que cette idée de dire le
souverainiste est quelqu'un qui pense
que la france va pouvoir résoudre tous
les problèmes c'est une sottise total
c'est une ces deux là encore je parler
d'avatar de moi-même ou d'avatar 2 2 2
de la revue ça c'est l'avatar du nom du
concept le souverainiste est quelqu'un
qui dit on est libre chez nous c'est pas
quelqu'un qui dit chez nous on
accueillera personne est chez nous on
parlera à personne ça c'est la métaphore
de l'asile on ne veut pas une france qui
soit un asile avec des avec des ddd
police militaire aux frontières des
polices des militaires aux frontières
dans les bateaux des sous-marins du côté
de l'atlantique de la manche david hare
année et puis avec l'espagne avec
l'italie avec la suisse avec la belgique
avec nos frontières on aurait des
barbelés et puis des miradors pays les
types qui passeraient avec des chiens en
disant nous ça y est on est
souverainiste je dis mais qu'est ce que
c'est que cette vision ridicule du
souverainisme le souverainiste c'est
quelqu'un qui dit je suis libre chez moi
si on prend une métaphore mois chez moi
j'habite dans un au cinquième étage d'un
appartement il ya donc cinq étages à
côté puis cinq étages à côté il ya dix
étages dont il ya donc dix familles
globalement le souverainiste et de dire
moi je suis chez moi je me lève à
monheurt je me couche à mon art je mange
ce que je mange pas si j'ai pas envie le
repas peut durer quinze minutes il peut
durer deux heures j'invite dix personnes
j'invite personnes dans mon frigidaire
ya ceux ci n'y a pas cela j'aime ses
voeux ses aliments y en a je les aime
pas y en a pas et ces souverainistes ça
quelqu'un qui dit ah bah non c'est plus
comme ça que ça va se passer alors le
souverainiste pas non plus quelqu'un qui
fait la gueule à son voisin c'est pas
quelqu'un qui mêle qui est qui qui met
la musique à fond en dix ans rien à
faire des voisins du dessous c'est
quelqu'un qui a le souci d'autrui mais
qui dit chez moi je suis chez moi de
même que son voisin en face il est chez
lui il fait ce qu'il veut et il a pas me
demander ce qu'il doit faire le
souverainiste c'est ça et money time et
trop de musique
il met trop de musique bas après ça
s'appelle le bon voisinage c'est le type
qui qui envahit vos frontières chez vous
en disant je rentre chez vous et l'armée
je bats quoi l'armée espagnole franchi
les pyrénées et rentrer en france bien
évidemment ce moment là on va la voir et
puis on lui dit au voisin je suis chez
moi ça fait un peu de bruit je pense que
ceci je n'ose que cela dit c'est un et
puis c'est quoi ça s'arrange que ça
s'arrange pas c'est un peu d'humain
c'est à dire que l'europe du général de
gaulle c'est l'europe des nations chaque
nation est autonome et indépendante
c'est-à-dire qu'elles passent des
contrats et donc si on fait par exemple
une recherche sur le noeud sur le sur le
virus par donc qu'on veut mettre au
point un vaccin il est bien évident
qu'on va travailler avec plein de pays
européens mais qu' on peut aussi
travailler avec des pays américains
qu'on peut aussi travailler avec jeux
pas qu'on a des néo zélandais des
australiens des indiens enfin tous les
gens qui bossent sur ce sur ce sujet là
le souverainiste c'est de l'art d'être
libre chez soi mais c'est aussi l'art de
contracter de manière les juristes
appellent ça de manière synallagmatique
un contrat synallagmatique si on passe
tous les deux si vous vous rompez le
contrat il est rompu si moi je le rond
et les rompus donc ce n'est pas un
contrat qui vous engage pour toujours
moyennant quoi je pense que l'on peut
faire par exemple une défense européenne
c'est tout à fait pour moi c'est tout à
fait envisageable
est ce qu'on doit partager les codes
nucléaires pas véritablement c'est à
dire qu'on peut mutualiser
l'anarchiste qui vous parle c'est le
proudhonien qui vous parlent se dire
qu'on peut mutualiser une armée
européenne même temps dire dans l'europe
on a des amis on a globalement que des
amis mais vous savez très bien comme ce
fait trahir que par ses amis c'est pas
nos ennemis qui nous trahissez un moment
donné ou il m'a fait ça a
vraiment si j'avais pu croire que oui à
un moment donné où vous avez d'un seul
coup un pays qui vous fait des crasses
alors que vous n'auriez jamais imaginer
une chose pareille il faut vous puissiez
continuer à disposer d'une arme
nucléaire qui est dissuasive en disant
bon on a déjà partagé nos armements
conventionnels
cet armement là on le garde parce que on
ne sait jamais il ya parfois des amis
qui deviennent ennemis et il faut pas
qu'on se soit désarmé sur ce terrain là
donc la conception le souverainisme
suppose une autre conception des
contrats c'est pas des contrats qui nous
enchaînent éternellement no 10 en a
signé une fois 92 maintenant c'est fini
pour la vie et dont vous avez vous allez
renoncer à tous non c'est la possibilité
de dire sur des sujets par exemple
erasme cette idée que des enfants des
jeunes et des jeunes des étudiants
puissent circuler étudiait depuis jean
qui rit oui bio qui rit
erasmus oui
j'ai pas compris franck biancheri qui
était à la base du pare d'avoir pardon
non mais je sais parler
on part sur une autre question russie
voulait
sainte sophie call et et n'utilise pas
500 sophie jonquet oui eh bien
j'ai lu pas mal de choses sur ce sujet
là et il vous dit quelque chose que je
n'ai pas lu je ne sais pas ce qui se dit
depuis mai fait trois ans que je vis à
paris les barrages
j'ai pas lu autant de choses que
j'aurais souhaité moi je suis pour
je suis souverainiste donc un
souverainiste est quelqu'un qui veut le
souverainisme pour tout le monde c'est à
dire que alors je serais plutôt
kémaliste entendons bien simplement le
kémalisme c'était atatürk il est plus là
mais il s'est passé des choses entre
deux de la même manière que je vous ai
dit qu'en 1905 il s'est passé des choses
est que depuis s'est passé d'autres
choses qu'il faut repenser la loi moi je
suis allé en turquie j'ai vu des
portraits de lui porter d'atatürk je me
suis dit pour la frime parce que je
pense que
datuk ne sont pas très heureux de voir
ce qui se passe en turquie c'est ainsi
la turquie est un pays souverain il ya
effectivement un bâtiment mais les
bâtiments ils sont leur histoire - dans
l'église de mon village il y a eu un
probablement un temple un temple païen
c'est toujours comme ça que ça se passe
qu'elle vous aviez une racine vous aviez
un
ruisseau vous aviez un rocher vous aviez
un arbre vous aviez pas des choses
particulières et puis un jour les
chrétiens sont arrivés puis sur ce lieu
ils ont construit c'est à dire donc il
ya 10 à des stratifications et
aujourd'hui quand les catholiques
viennent eux de recevoir l'eucharistie
dans l'église de chambois ils sont pas
là pour ils sont pas en train de vénérer
la source par exemple qui était
probablement sous sol de la de l'église
et un jour que je suis entrain de
l'église y avait des mains ils ont
revanche il y avait une espèce de
friselis sur des pavés et en fait je me
suis renseigné mais débat c'est une
source qui remonte c'est extraordinaire
c'est la sauce païenne qui a donc
sainte-sophie c'est une construction
tout à fait particulière donc chrétienne
puis musulmane puis après dans le
politiquement correct du musée universel
où c'est devenu un grand temple de la
delà de l'année du tourisme et de la
consommation quand j'y suis allé bon ben
voilà à quoi il ya déjà des touristes ça
va ça vient et ses terrasses et c'est
devenu un c'est devenu un musée et d'un
seul coup un pays musulman nous dit mais
c'est peut-être amusé mais c'est aussi
un lieu de culte et si ça a été un lieu
de culte chrétien c'est devenu un lieu
de culte musulman avant de cesser de
l'être pour les raisons troalen
kémaliste ils veulent restaurer ce lieu
comme un lieu de culte libre à eux la
turquie n'appartient qu'à la turquie les
les monuments turc appartiennent à la
turquie lusage des monuments turc
appartiennent à la turquie n'ont pas
d'autorisation a demandé à l'europe où
au politiquement correct américain en
disant ce monsieur train parce que vous
accepteriez que etc monsieur georges
soros êtes vous d'accord pour que
bernard henri lévy ce que vous donnez un
trop tôt risation pour et enfin toutes
ces président de la république ou macron
comment durable j'ai pas bien ceux ci se
doit bien cela moi j'estime que les
mules que les pays je ne suis pas
souverainiste pour la france qui s'ouvre
à nice pour tous les pays c'est pourquoi
je quand nous parlions tout à l'heure
d'immigration je pense que le mali doit
être souverain la mauritanie doivent
doit être souverain que la libye doit
être souveraine et que si la libye à
cesser dette souveraine depuis justement
les agissements de sarkozy de bhl et de
quelques autres on se dit aujourd'hui
comme par hasard ces fameux turc alors
je défends les turcs quand ils les
islamise un bâtiment mais je ne
défendrai pas quand il s'en viennent
s'installer en libye en disant on va
maintenant faire la loi ici avec le
silence un peu complice d'ailleurs des
états unis il faudrait qu'on s'entende
là dessus pour pouvoir un peu qu'elle
joue quel jeu joue erdogan qui est pas
un jeu compliqué à comprendre quand on a
compris quel rôle il jouer en europe et
sur le terrain planétaire donc là moi je
pense que ce celui ce lieu deviendra un
lieu de culte mais assez probablement
comme notre dame de paris c'est de
mauvais exemple actuellement mais je
dirais les est un lieu de culte mais
aussi un lieu touristique donc il y aura
probablement la possibilité de réserver
des heures pour le culte est peut-être
la possibilité moi je vous félicite et
beaucoup de mosquées beaucoup de
synagogues beaucoup d'églises dans ma
vie de dire que en dehors des heures du
culte et à la possibilité de visiter ce
qui au demeurant reste quand même un
immense chef-d'oeuvre architectural
question internet quels sont selon lui
les trois plus grands visqueux
systémique pour la civilisation
européenne dans le vin temps à venir que
devrait être selon lui la résilience
française fasse *
si vous permettrait de faire un petit
office tic mais je pense que les trois
dans son camp et c'est la démographie
parce qu'elle conditionne le doubs alors
la démo gratuite au pour le coup une
science exacte c'est à dire que c'est
parce qu'elle est une science exacte
elle autant détesté aujourd'hui donc
personne ne nie que la géologie est une
science exacte que la chimie est une
science exacte mais la démographie
allant leur dis maintenant on peut lui
faire dire n'importe quoi on peut se
tromper j'ai lu tout à l'heure en venant
vous retrouver dans le taxi que l'onu
s'était trompé de 2 milliards d'humains
sur les prédictions des prévisions
qu'elle avait fait de la population dans
les 20 prochaines années donc évidemment
on peut effectivement estimé que c'est
pas forcément toujours une science
exacte si c'est pratiqué par des
amateurs ce n'est pas une science exacte
mais quand les démographes ont des
projections ils nous disent des choses
qui sont très claires c'est à dire que
si vous regardez le taux de fécondité
des blancs pour aller vite et on mettra
des majuscules je suis pas le new york
times qui met des majuscules la black et
des minuscules à white je mets 10
majuscule à blanc je me des majuscules à
noir ou aux gens de couleur etc vous
regardez les taux de fécondité ne serait
ce d'ailleurs que indépendamment des
couleurs parce que pour le coup c'est
une erreur que je suis en train de
commettre sa à avoir plus avec la
religion qu avec les couleurs c'est à
dire que vous vous apercevez que les
catholiques qui utilisent la pilule les
contraceptifs etc font très peu
d'enfants il ya très peu de cas tollé
que sauf les ultras qui sont dans des
logiques de famille nombreuse mais la
fécondité des gens qui disent à crissey
la religion musulmane est plus
importante parce que c'est une
bénédiction de dieu parce qu'il ya cette
idée que quand vous faites des enfants
c'est un cadeau que vous fait à dieu et
que vous acceptez donc depuis qu'est ce
que vous avez toujours cette logique
tribale c'est à dire que ça existe
encore la famille chez les musulmans il
ya le père il ya la mer chacun à sa
place son rôle qui est les frères et les
soeurs et cousins et à ses tailleurs
très honorable je trouve très bien que
qu'on puisse célébrer la famille quand
c'est celle ci mais quand ce sont
d'autres aussi quelque forme qu'elle
prenne donc je pense que on pourrait
dire il ya ceux ci à cela il ya cela
mais je pense que si on dit il y à la
démographie et c'est effectivement la
démographie qui va entraîner la
disparition de la fameuse europe du
général de gaulle c'est à dire
gréco-romaine judéo-chrétienne et est de
race blanche donc bon voilà le général
de gaulle a dit c'était ainsi il avait
raison depuis qu'il a dit ça aujourd'hui
ça a cessé d'être le cas nadine morano
khabar a beau jeu de répéter la phrase
du général de gaulle c'est fini c'est
trop tard c'est ainsi et ça c'est la
démographie et je voudrais en profiter
pour dire que quand il s'agit du grand
emplacement si je parle du grand
emplacement va tout de suite me dire
attention renaud camus de teint
fascistes et nazis c'est bien la preuve
que ceux ci c'est là tout a donc les
gens sinon il n'y a pas de grands
placement je ne voudrais surtout pas
être assimilé à renaud camus et vous
lisez oria bouteldja dans les noirs les
juifs et nous où elle dit oui le grand
remplacement c'est nous donc le grand
accomplissement existe c'est elle qui le
dit donc il faudrait savoir si c'est
renaud camus c'est pas bien parce que
c'est un vin un poncif de l'extrême
droite 6 et horia bouteldja qui le dit
qui le revendique et qui s'en réjouit on
trouve ça formidable alors yat-il
remplacement est il pas un grand
remplacement par l'interrogation jeudi
demandons démographe pour ce que d'une
démographie nous disent ils nous disent
les taux de fécondité des familles
musulmanes ne sont pas les taux de
fécondité des familles judéo chrétienne
tout ça va très vite il faudrait que je
sois démographe et que je puisse affiner
un petit peu précisé être un petit peu
subtil dans ce que je vous dis mais il
est bien évident que dans deux ou trois
générations on parlera plus de
civilisation blanche judéo chrétienne en
europe ça me paraît évident donc le la
disparition de l'europe s'effectuera
avec les taux de fécondité de natalité
en relation avec les idéologies
familialiste qui sont elles mêmes en
relation avec les spiritualités kylie
kylie suppose la spiritualité musulmane
est une spiritualité avec une forte
démographie des spiritualités blanche
occidentale sur des spiritualités avec
de petites démographie c'est pas
compliqué à un moment donné où cette
europe que j'ai connu vous aussi un peu
mais vous êtes beaucoup plus jeune que
moi cette europe et disparaîtra et je ne
suis pas de ceux qui disent bien fait
pour sa gueule à la roya bouteldja par
exemple ou du genre c'est pas possible
il faut qu'on se ressaisisse et il faut
qu'on fasse quelque chose comme renaud
camus vous avez un optimiste et un
pessimiste l'optimiste l'optimisme de
doya bouteldja le pessimisme de de
renaud camus moi je suis sur une logique
tragique c'est ainsi de la même manière
que notre titanic a déjà perçu percuté
le l'iceberg le processus démographique
est engagé c'est ainsi en question
internet est ce qu'ils ne voient pas de
souci a parlé entre guillemets ou non du
peuple alors qu'il ne représente que lui
oui mais ça c'est une remarque
extrêmement juste parce que si on
m'interdit l'essentialisation je ne peux
plus rien dire de ce que j'aurais dit on
dira il dit les musulmans nom de quoi
parle-t-il des musulmans il pas lui même
musulman et puis il a dit les musulmans
c'était sale et moi je connais un
musulman qui ne dit pas ce pas oui
d'accord il a entièrement d'accord ces
deux personnes a entièrement raison
d'estimer que le peuple c'est pas moi
mais je souhaiterais qu'on puisse faire
la démonstration que j'ai dit une fois
un tour que le peuple c'est dément je ne
suis pas dans cette logique mégalomane
et je n'ai jamais dit que je parlais
pour le peuple je dis qu'effectivement
j'entends des choses qui dont le peuple
des voix qui disent que et puis voilà
j'ai donné ma définition du peuple une
fois encore j'ai pas dit le peuple c'est
moi je dis le peuple c'est l'ensemble de
ceux sur lesquels le pouvoir s'exerce et
qui ne disposent eux-mêmes que d'aucuns
d'aucun pouvoir ont peu de très peu de
pouvoir et était dans mon dans dans mon
projet de dire je suis le peuple j'en
parle je suis le tribun de la plèbe la
plèbe et le peuple n'a plus à parler il
suffit juste qu'ils m'écoutent donc là
c'est un commentaire internet ce n'est
pas une question d'ailleurs 10 pouces
acquisition commentaires lors il devrait
pas pousser ses commentaires il dit on
ferait un pseudo philosophe une honte
pour la france et pour son passé savant
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre elle
que j'aimerais qu'elle augmente
week end moi je veux bien être la honte
pour le passé ça avant de la france mais
se défile devant c'est pas grave moi
j'ai pas gg je me lève pas le matin je
suis un philosophe et je veux qu'on
m'appelle monsieur le philosophe ou tu
pas réussi ce monsieur pense que je suis
par la philosophe c'est pas grave s'ils
pensent que je suis non pour la france
c'est pas grave non plus vous savez je
me moque absolument de ce que ce
monsieur dont je ne sais rien on peut
penser de moi à partir de cet entretien
d'ailleurs toujours pas pourquoi perdre
du temps à écouter si je suis pas un
philosophe qui ferait bien de regarder
cyril hanouna ça doit être à peu près en
même temps ça donne plutôt dans ses
cordes c'est bien on me dira c'est de
bonne guerre c'est une réponse de pseudo
philosophe à quelqu'un qui doit le
trouver plus
d autres choses qui coûtent autre chose
un autre on ferait devenu louche on
dirait un daniel cohn bendit améliorée
du libéralisme libertaire vous a reconnu
je la relis oui non j'ai compris quand
même assez confus mais j'ai quand même
compris en raw juin la libérale libéral
libertaire je suis cohn-bendit peut-être
qu'un pédophile et si vous me conseillez
de cet avantage
et les usages du haschich et je sais pas
enfin et d'autres choses mais enfin je
ne mets je veux bien que tous ces gens
là disent ce qu'ils disent mais en même
temps c'est un jeu difficile et vous
assassiner les gens en trois phrases et
nous ne démontre rien donc moi je veux
bien et reims ou philosophes par un
philosophe un sou cohn-bendit etc faut
juste dire en quoi je suis anti libéral
ça fait à peu près trente ans que je dis
que je suis un libéral ça fait à peu
près trente ans que je dis que je suis
anti libérale le libertaire que je suis
je n'ai jamais caché j'ai simplement dit
que il y avait plusieurs façons d'être
libertaire et que ma façon d'être
libertaire lt pro donne yens et je n'ai
jamais caché ces choses là non plus donc
le pro denise n'est pas un cohn-bendit
mme et je suis pas du tout dans les
logiques de ce monsieur dont le dans le
grand fait d'armes intellectuelle depuis
30 ans consiste à dire que l'europe
libérale c'est ce qu'il ya de plus beau
alors que depuis trente ans je dit
l'europe libérale c'est ce qu'il ya pire
mais si ce monsieur ou sept personnes
pensent que je suis un cohn-bendit caché
qu'il dévoile l'imposture et qu'ils en
fassent un livre que pense-t-il des
black blocks
donc là aussi c'est difficile de faire
une sociologie de quelque chose qui qui
échappe à la sociologie puisque vous
l'aurez constaté d'ailleurs c'est
quelque chose de très intéressant jamais
on interroge un black bloc jamais c'est
à dire que vous avez des journalistes
ils sont là ils vous chope un gilet
jaune et comme et c'est par hasard
évidemment se relève toujours par hasard
on n'a jamais la méthodologie du à 300
personnes et on a demandé à telle
personne on la choisit pour ceux ci pour
cela que c'était il ya plein de black
blocks des journalistes qui les filme à
longueur de temps c'est à dire qu'on a
vu avec les gilet jaune pendant les dd
samedi à la queue leu leu des gens qui
sont des black blocs qui foutent le feu
qui arrachent des grilles qui balancent
des toiles dans les vitrines et c'est
pas un journaliste a dit venez rester
masqué par les nous dites nous qui vous
êtes expliquez-nous votre sociologie
vous avez quel âge vous faites quoi dans
la vie vous êtes mariés vous avez des
enfants des diplômes un boulot quel est
votre pouvoir d'achat quels sont vos
quel est votre idéologie vous luttez
pourquoi vous faites ça pour quelle
raison est ce que vous pensez que en
jetant une grille d'égout sur un abribus
vous fait avancer vraiment la cause du
prolétariat jamais jamais ce que je
constate c'est que donc on laisse les
black blocks
être invisible on ne sait pas ce qu'ils
pensent véritablement et quand ils se
mettent à
assiéger le l'arc de triomphe eh bien il
enfile un gilet jaune ce sont des gilet
jaune et comme par hasard les
journalistes les suivre caméra sur
l'épaule mais là il n'y a pas un flic
pour les suivants y'a pas un flic pour
les suivre c'est à dire que on les
laisse faire
on a tagué le fait tous ces gens là ont
tagué les mêmes l'arc de triomphe il y
avait sur l'arc de triomphe des tags
franchement black blogs etc justice pour
adama traoré enfin ce genre de chose
était sûre le justice poids dramaturge
et adama traoré on sait connaît dans
l'est des colonialistes et racialiste
était bien seul coup il faut les
associer au gilet jaune
le la base de l'arc de triomphe est
constellé de deux tableaux j'ai vu ça en
regardant j'ai fait un livre qui
s'appelle grandeur du petit peuple et je
me suis dit je vais chercher une
iconographie sur le net j'ai cherché une
et canaux graphie sur le net
qu'est ce que je vois l'arc de triomphe
un tag gilet jaune vaincrons tous les
autres tags effacés je suis dit mais
c'est quand même bien je voudrais bien
retrouver cette photo que j'ai bien vu
en tête puisqu'il y avait le à dans le
rond symbole anarchiste justice pour
adama traoré et c'est donc dès décide de
le dit antifa qui fasciste et tous
avaient été effacés et il ne restait
plus que cette seule phrase gilet jaune
vaincrons pour quelle raison il
s'agissait de dire les gilet jaune sont
des casseurs il faut discréditer les
gilet jaune moyennant quoi il ya des
gens qui les discrédite et qui sont
formidables ce sont les black blocks je
pense que les black blocks sont les
idiots utiles du pouvoir mac rognan ils
sont instrumentalisés par castaner qui
dit allez-y on les laisse faire on ne me
fera pas croire qu'on n'a pas la
possibilité de d'interpeller des gens
qui sont black blocks ils sont vêtus
comme ça ils ont le ils ont ils ont le
cas ce qu'ils sont invisibles ils ont un
foulard l'album qui sont habillés de
noir et ils sont en bande et jamais
d'interpellations en revanche des gilet
jaune qui ont perdu des yeux des bras
des mains des doigts etc alors là il y
en a qu entité
les black blocs non il arrive on sait
pas ils surgissent de nulle part ils
cassent tout il ya disparaissent on les
voit plus aucune interpellation rien ni
personne pas de chef pas de pas de
réseau rien du tout une impossibilité de
faire une traçabilité et à la manif
suivante on y retrouve manière suivante
on les retrouve à la mission entend les
retours ont dit mais qu'est ce qui se
passe pour que ces gens n'en ai pas la
sociologie on n'est pas le visage on en
n'est pas le questionnement les
journalistes ne ne le ne me questionne
jamais ou éventuellement faire un 52
minutes sur bfm en disant on vous file
notre carte on organise votre visibilité
et vous aller témoigner à visage couvert
et puis on passe cinq en dix minutes et
vous allez nous expliquer ce que vous
êtes ce que vous faites pour quoi vous
le fait qu'ils et c'est à ça ne se fait
jamais donc je ne vais pas théoriser sur
les black block the theory simplement
sur la sociologie des black blocks je
vois qu'ils existent qu'ils commettent
leurs forfaits qu'on les laisse
commettre ses forfaits et que d'une
certaine manière quand il s'agit sur le
net d'effacer la trace de leurs forfaits
on les efface parce qu'il s'agit une
fois encore de stigmatiser le peuple qui
serait le seul le personnage détestable
dans cette aventure
est-ce que vous avez étudie krishnamurti
s'est fait partie des questions qu'on
pose de régulièrement et on invite à le
lire envoyer les livres ou cas où je ne
les aurais pas eu dans ma bibliothèque
où il m'est arrivé d'en lire mais c'est
une littérature à laquelle je suis resté
étranger parce que je reste un
occidental quoi c'est à dire que moi
j'ai vu des études de philo et c'est
quand même fait un siècle de penser si
on le pouvoir simba un peu un peu
correctement on peut pas s'occuper de
philosophie indienne de philosophie
chinoise de philosophie japonaise de
philosophie diverses et multiples j'ai
fait ma première année de thèse parce
que ça n'existait pas quand même je suis
retourné à caen suite mais il y avait
des enseignants d'histoire des religions
et des enseignants de la pensée indienne
ou 17 cd rom la promotion mais le
shintoïsme bah oui je connais pas la
liste le totémisme je connais pas
vraiment beaucoup donc de fait si si on
veut travailler sur les grandes surfaces
sont détriment de la profondeur et puis
si on veut travailler en profondeur je
dis pas qu'ils travaillent en profondeur
mais j'ai quand même une contre histoire
de la philosophie
je me suis pris toutes ces histoires de
vie des présocratiques jusqu'à robert
misrahi est encore vivant et donc
qu'elle n'a mortier quelqu'un que j'ai
un peu lure me disant que je n'y
trouvais rien de beaucoup plus original
que ce qu'on trouve déjà chez pythagore
par exemple on vous recommande
sa vidéo qui teinte sur internet de 1985
à l'onu d'accord ça passe par là on
arrive bientôt la fin de notre interview
un train à prendre
comme vous ils vous allez vous rejoindre
la gare à pied on va vous laisser un peu
plus de temps est ce que vous pouvez me
conseillez trois bouquins
comme ça dans la rue comme ça
j'ai beaucoup fait j'ai beaucoup lu
dreux 2 des romans qu ai je ne lis plus
de romont donc je vous dit tout à
l'heure que je manquais enfin je me
court après le temps et que je me
l'interdis effectivement de regarder
beaucoup de vos émissions mais je me
rematter dit le théâtre l'opéra ou même
le cinéma et donc je lis très très peu
de romans donc je vais conseiller plutôt
trois classiques et qui sont des
classiques de la philo pour le coup
je vais éviter tout ce qui est un peu
technique est compliqué se sert à rien
de dun vite et à lire des livres qui
demandent des années de pratique
philosophique je commencerai par quel
est ce qu'il ya à peu près de plus
simple sur les lettres à lucilius de
sénèque
ce sont des maîtres de vérité qui
enseigne à des disciples sur des choses
éminemment concrètes pas de théorie
j'adore les romains j'ai fait un livre
s'appelle sagesse qui est une
réhabilitation de la totalité de la
pensée romaine contre la pensée grecque
qui est très qui est fait pour les
philosophes qui fait pour philosopher la
philosophie romaine elle est faite pour
être pratiqué et sénèque écrit à
lucilius son jeune élève ce qu'il faut
faire comment il faut se comporter
devant l'amour la mort la souffrance les
honneurs des richesses la blessure la
trahison et c'est formidable et c'est
compréhensible par tout le monde au dans
un deuxième temps mais mais le premier
temps suffirait pas ce qu'ils s'en
inspirent beaucoup ces montagnes sont
les essais de montaigne
dans la traduction de mon ami de mon
regretté ami était bernard combeaud chez
mollat et et la faune la collection
bouquins parce que c'est difficile de
lire montagne dans le texte c'est même
très difficile il ya des textes qui sont
un peu il ya des éditions qui sont un
peu arrangés dernière combo avant de
décéder
j'ai pas le temps de parler de bernard
mais il a fait des choses
extraordinaires notamment une traduction
lucrèce qui respecte la métrique de
lucrèce donc les verts et ee il a m'a
dit mais il me disait mais je reprises
et je rebrousse commune vieilles
tapisseries il faut pas que ça se voit
sur ce il ya des trous il faut qu'on
fasse le nécessaire pour que les gens ne
voient pas du tout il a fait ça avec le
style de montaigne et donc c'est très
visible donc c'est surtout sur tous les
sujets sa part a cédé non chapitre des
courts chapitres rien de technique c'est
d'une certaine manière un sénèque du à
seneffe du 16e siècle et puis un
troisième livre qui serait politiquement
un contemporain de montaigne qui est la
boétie discours sur la servitude
volontaire petit texte sublime nous dit
que le pouvoir n'existe que parce que
nous y consentent ont ils disent c'est
un colosse dont nous sommes les pieds
supprimons la puissance au pouvoir il
n'a plus la puissance donc il n'ya du
pouvoir que parce que vous donnez du
pouvoir au prince alors oui c'est pas
bien il ya des tyrans et des autocrates
etc mais s'il ya des tyrans c'est parce
que vous ne vous revenez pas la belle
phrase d'un labo ici il a 17 ans quand
il écrit ce texte là c'est soyez résolus
de ne plus servir et vous voilà libres
une petite question pour monsieur onfray
qui vient d'internet rené guénon estimé
que la création des nations en europe et
est révélateur du fait que la
civilisation européenne ait perdu son
essence et qu en conséquence les nations
étaient une création identitaire et
culturelle fictives pour pallier à un
manque
il opposait ainsi l'occident et l'orient
ce dernier ayant conservé des entités
civiles civilisationnel bien plus
profonde que pensez vous de ce point de
vue est il toujours d'actualité
alors de la même manière j'ai tout à
l'heure que j'étais assez ignorant dans
toutes les philosophies un occidental je
dirais que je suis aussi ignorants de
toutes les philosophies occultistes et
rené guénon fait partie des occultistes
j'ai lu une époque la crise du monde
moderne ya très longtemps j'ai repris ça
il ya bien peu de temps sam est un peu
tombé des mains parce que je trouve que
c'est
c'est dans un style très prophétique et
je n'aime pas vraiment beaucoup le style
prophétique part je suis pas comme ce
monsieur là qui estime que c'est pas un
philosophe se serait pas un philosophe
parce que ça reste à démontrer c'est une
pensée mais c'est une pensée assez
oecuméniques qui estime que l'occident
était dévitalisées que d'une certaine
manière un peu de la spiritualité
orientale ferait du bien à notre
civilisation qui se fonderait qui après
il ya toute une théorie des cycles une
philosophie de l'histoire qui pour moi
est plus religieuse que philosophique
est-ce que vous avez un conseil pour les
jeunes générations
d'impérissables une bouteille à la mer
bah oui de de lire la boétie de
comprendre que le mécanisme du pouvoir
de savoir que le pouvoir est partout et
que la résistance est susceptible d'être
partout aussi et qu' on ne peut rien
contre quelqu'un qui a décidé qu'on
aurait pas de pouvoir sur lui il ya dans
un film que j'adore qui s'appelait zéro
de conduite de jean vigo un grand film
libertaire anarchiste pas au sens
libertaire de cohn-bendit des gamins qui
font et c'est une tyrannie dans un dans
un collège et un moment donné il faut
une bataille de polochons et vigo film
ça ralentit et envoie les plumes qui
explosent et c est quand les enfants ont
compris que la tyrannie n'était pas
problématique parce qu'il y avait du
tyran mais que la tyrannie des
problématiques parce qu'ils consentaient
à la puissance du tyran d'un seul coup
ils font ils font cette espèce de
chamb'art et de et de bataille de
polochons si les jeunes savent qu
effectivement le monde qui existent
n'existe que parce qu'ils y consentent
il suffit qu'il me concentre plus pour
que ce monde là ne soient plus même que
un autre jalon frein merci c'est moi
[Musique]